hey everyone welcome to Simply learn
today we will learn the fundamentals of
cloud computing and cloud computing
service models that said if these are
the types of videos you would like to
watch then hit the like And subscribe
button and the bell icon to get notified
and just a quick info for you if you
want to upskill yourself and master
cloud computing skills and landar your
dream job to grow in your career then
you must explore simply learns cohort of
various cloud computing programs simply
learn offers various certifications and
postgraduate programs in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like celtech it guati AWS
and many more through our courses you
will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like serverless
Computing containerization and
orchestration VPC design and
implementation and over a dozen others
and that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts that is
is working in top pair product companies
and academicians from top universities
after completing these courses thousands
of Learners have transitioned into a
cloud computing role as a fresher or
moved on to a higher paying job and
profile if you are passionate about
making your career in this field then
make sure to check out the link in the
pin comment and description box below to
find a cloud computing program that fits
your experience and areas of Interest
before cloud computing existed if we
need any it servers or application let's
say a basic web server it does not come
easy now here is an owner of a business
and I know you would have guessed it
already that he's running a successful
business by looking at the hot and fresh
brewed coffee in his desk and lots and
lots of paper work to review and approve
now he had a smart not only smart
looking but a really smart worker in his
office called Mark and on one fine day
he called Mark and said that he would
like to do business online in other
words he would like like to take his
business online and for that he needed
his own website as the first thing and
Mark puts all his knowledge together and
comes up with this requirement that his
boss would need lots of servers uh
database and softwares to get his
business online which means a lot of
investment and Mark also adds that his
boss will need to invest on acquiring
technical expertise to manage the
hardware and software that they will be
purchasing and also to monitor the
infrastructure and after hearing all
this his boss was close to dropping his
plan to go online but before he made a
decision he chose to check if there are
any alternatives where he don't have to
spend a lot of money and don't have to
spend acquiring technical expertise now
that's when Mark opened this discussion
with his boss and he explained his boss
about cloud computing and he explained
his boss the same thing that I'm going
to explain to you in sometime now about
what is cloud computing what is cloud
computing cloud computing is the use of
a network of remote servers hosted on
the internet to store manage and process
data rather than having all that locally
and using local server for that cloud
computing is also storing our data in
the internet from anywhere and accessing
our data from anywhere throughout the
internet and the companies that offer
those services are called Cloud
providers cloud computing is also being
able to deploy and manage our
applications services and network
throughout the globe and manage them
through the web management or
configuration portal in other words
cloud computing service providers give
us the ability to manage our
applications and services through a
Global Network or Internet example of
such providers are Amazon web servers
and Microsoft Azure now that we have
known what cloud computing is let's talk
about the benefits of cloud computing
now I need to tell you the cloud
benefits is what is driving Cloud
adoption like anything in the recent
days if you want an IT resource or a
service now with Cloud it's available
for me almost instantaneously and it's
ready for production almost the same
time now this reduces the goal live date
and the product and the service hit the
market almost instantaneously compared
to the Legacy environment and because of
this the companies have started to
generate Revenue almost the next day if
not the same day planning and buying the
right siiz Hardware has always been a
challenge in Legacy environment and if
you're not careful when doing this we
might need to live with a hardware
that's undersized for the rest of our
lives with Cloud we do not buy any
hardware but we use the hardware and pay
for the time we use it if that Hardware
does not fit our requirement release it
and start using a better configuration
and pay only for the time you use that
new and better configuration in Legacy
environments forecasting demand is an
full-time job but with Cloud you can let
the monitoring and automation tool to
work for you and to rapidly scale up and
down the resources based on the need of
that R not only that the resources
Services data can be accessed from
anywhere as long as we are connected to
the internet and even there are tools
and techniques now available which will
let you to work offline and will sync
whenever the internet is available
making sure the data is stored in
durable storage and in a secure fashion
is the talk of the business and Cloud
answers that million dooll question with
Cloud the data can be stored in an
highly durable storage and replicated to
multiple regions if you want and uh the
data that we store is encrypted and
secured in a fashion that's beyond what
we can imagine in local data centers now
let's bleed into the discussion about
the types of cloud computing very lately
there are multiple ways to categorize
cloud computing because because it's
ever growing now we have more categories
out of all these six sort of stand out
you know categorizing cloud based on
deployments and categorizing cloud based
on services and again under deployments
categorizing them based on how they have
been implemented you know is it private
is it public or is it hybrid and again
categorizing them based on the service
it provides is it infrastructure as a
service or is it platform as a service
or is it software as a service let's
look at them one by one let's talk about
the different types of cloud based on
the deployment models first in public
Cloud everything is stored and accessed
in and through the internet and um any
internet users with proper permissions
can be given access to some of the
applications and resources and in public
Cloud we literally own nothing be it the
hardware or software everything is
managed by the provider AWS Azure and
Google are some examples of public Cloud
private Cloud on the other hand with
private Cloud the infrastructure is
exclusively for an single organization
the organizations can choose to run
their own cloud locally or choose to
Outsource it to a public cloud provider
as manag services and when this is done
the service the infrastructure will be
maintained on a private Network some
examples are wmware cloud and some of
the AWS products are very good example
for private Cloud hybrid cloud has taken
things to the whole new level with
hybrid Cloud we get the benefit of both
public and private Cloud organizations
will choose to keep some of their
applications locally and some of the
application will be present in the cloud
one good example is NASA it uses hybrid
Cloud it uses private Cloud to store
sensitive data and uses public Cloud to
store and share data which are not
sensitive or confidential let's now
discuss about cloud based on servers
model the first and the broad category
is infrastructure as a service uh here
we would rent the servers network
storage and we'll pay for them in an
early basis but we will have access to
the resources we provision and for some
we will have root level access as well
ec2 in AWS is a very good example it's a
Wim for which we have root level access
to the OS and admin access to the
hardware the next type of service model
would be platform as a service now in
this model the providers will give me a
pre-built platform where we can deploy
our codes and our applications and they
will be up and running we only need to
manage the codes and not the
infrastructure here in software as a
service the cloud providers sell the end
product which is a software or an
application and we directly buy the
software on an subscription basis it's
not the infra or the platform but the
end product or the software or a fun
functioning application and we pay for
the hours we use the software and in
here the client maintains full control
of the software and does not maintain
any equipment Amazon and Azure also sell
products that are software as service
this chart sort of explains the
difference between the four models
starting from on premises to
infrastructure as a service to platform
as a service to software as a service
this is self-explanatory that uh the
resource man managed by us are huge in
on premises that towards your left as
you watch and it's little less in
infrastructure as a service as we move
further towards the ride and further
reduced in platform as a service and
there's really nothing to manage when it
comes to software as a service because
we buy the software not any
infrastructure component attached to it
now let's talk about the life cycle of
the cloud computing solution the very
first thing in the life cycle of a
solution or a cloud solution is to get a
proper understanding of the requirement
I didn't say get the requirement but
said get a proper understanding of the
requirement it is very vital because
only then we will be able to properly
pick the right service offered by the
provider getting a sound understanding
the next thing would be to define the
hardware meaning choose the compute
service that will provide the right
support where you can resize the compute
capacity in the cloud to run application
programs getting a sound and
understanding of the requirement helps
in picking the right Hardware one size
does not fit all there are different
services and Hardwares for different
needs you might have like ec2 if you're
looking for is and Lambda if you're
looking for serverless computing and ECS
that provides containerized servers so
there are a lot of Hardwares available
pick the right Hardware that suits your
requirement the third thing is to define
the storage choose the apprpriate
storage service where you can backup
your data and a separate storage service
where you can archive your data locally
within the cloud or from the internet
and choose the appropriate storage there
is one separately for backup called S3
and there's one separately for archival
that's for Glacier so you know you
knowing the difference between them
really helps in picking the right
service for the right kind of need
Define the network Define the network
that securely delivers data video and
applications Define and identify the
Network Services properly for example
VPC for Network Route 53 for DNS and
direct connection for private P2P line
from your office to the AWS data center
set up the right Security Services IM am
for authentication and authorization and
KMS for uh data encryption at rest so
there are variety of security products
available we got to pick the right one
that suits our need and there are
variety of deployment and Automation and
monitoring tools that you can pick from
for example Cloud watch is for
monitoring Autos scaling is for being
elastic and Cloud formation is Define
the management process and tools you can
have complete control of your Cloud
environment if you define the management
tools which monitors your AWS resources
and are the custom applications running
on AWS platform there are variety of
deployment Automation and monitoring
tools you can pick from like Cloud watch
for monitoring Auto scaling for
Automation and cloud formation for a
deployment so knowing them will help you
in defining the life cycle of the cloud
computer in solution properly and
similarly there are a lot of tools for
testing a process like code star and
code build and code pipeline these are
tools with which you can build test and
deploy your code quickly and finally
once everything is set and done pick the
analytic service for analyzing and
visualizing the data using the analytics
Services where we can start quering the
data instantly and get a result now if
you want to visually view the happenings
in your environment you can pick atena
and other tool tools for analytics are
EMR and uh which is elastic map produce
and Cloud search thanks guys now we have
Samuel and Rahul to take us through the
full course in which they will explain
basic framework of Amazon web services
and explore all of its important
services like ec2 Lambda S3 IM am and
cloud formation we'll also talk about
Azure and some of its popular Services
hello everyone let me introduce myself
as Sam a multiplatform cloud architect
and trainer and I'm so glad and I'm
equally excited to talk and walk you
through this session about what AWS is
and talk to you about some services and
offerings and about how companies get
benefited by migrating their
applications and infra into AWS so
what's AWS let's talk about that now
before that let's talk about how life
was without any cloud provider and in
this case how life was without aw so
let's walk back and picture how things
were back in 2000 which is not so long
long ago but lot of changes lot of
changes for better had happened since
that time now back in 2000 a request for
a new server is not an happy thing at
all because lot of uh money lot of
validations lot of planning are involved
in getting a server online or up and
running and even after we've finally got
the server it's not all said and done
there a lot of optimization that needs
to be done on that server to make it
worth it and get a good good return on
investment from that server and uh even
after we have optimized for a good
return on investment the work is still
not done there will often be a frequent
increase and decrease in the capacity
and you know even news about our website
getting popular and getting more hits
It's still an Bittersweet experience
because now I need to add more servers
to the environment which means that it's
going to cost me even more but thanks to
the present day Cloud technology if the
same situation were to happen today my
new server it's almost ready and it's
ready instantaneously and with the Swift
tools and technologies that Amazon is
providing of in provisioning my server
instantaneously and adding any type of
workload on top of it and making my
storage and server secure you know
creating a durable storage where data
that I store in the cloud never gets
lost with all that features Amazon has
got our back so let's talk about what is
AWS there are a lot of definitions for
it but uh I'm going to put together a
simple and a precise definition as much
as possible now let me iron that out
Cloud still runs on and Hardware right
and uh there are certain features in
that infrastructure in that cloud
infrastructure that makes cloud cloud or
that makes AWS a cloud provider now we
get all the services all the
Technologies all the features and all
the benefits that we get in our local
data center like you know security and
compute capacity and uh databases and in
fact you know we get even more cool
features like uh content caching in
various global locations around the
planet but again out of all the features
the best part is that I get or we get
everything on a pay as we go model the
less I use the less I pay and the more I
use the less I pay per unit very
attractive isn't it right and that's not
all the applications that we provision
in AWS are very reliable because they
run on an reliable infrastructure and
it's very scalable because it runs on an
ond demand infrastructure and it's very
flexible because of the designs and
because of the design options available
for me in the cloud let's talk about how
all this happened AWS was launched in uh
20 2 after the Amazon we know as the
online retail store wanted to sell their
REM remaining or unused infrastructure
as a service or as an offering for
customers to buy and use it from them
you know sell infrastructure as a
service the idea sort of clicked and AWS
launched their first product first
product in 2006 that's like 4 years
after the idea launch and in 2012 they
held a big-sized customer even to gather
inputs and concerns from customers and
they were very dedicated in making those
requests happen and that habit is still
being followed it's still being followed
as U reinvent by AWS and at 2015 Amazon
announced its Revenue to be 4.6 billion
and in 2015 through 2016 AWS launched
products and services that help migrate
customer services into AWS well they web
products even before but this is when a
lot of focus was given on developing
migrating services and in the same year
that's in 2016 Amazon's revenue was 10
billion and not but not the least as we
speak Amazon has more than 100 products
and services available for customers and
get benefited from all right let's talk
about the uh services that are available
in Amazon let's start with this product
called S3 now s 3 is a great tool for
internet backup and it's it's the
cheapest storage option in the object
storage category and not only that the
data that we put in S3 is retriable from
the internet S3 is really cool and we
have other products like migration and
data collection and data transfer
products and here we can not only
collect data seamlessly but also in a
realtime way monitor the data or analyze
the data that's being received that the
cool products like uh AWS data transfers
available that helps achieve that and
then we have products like uh ec2
elastic compute Cloud that's an
resizable computer where we can anytime
anytime alter the size of the computer
based on the need or based on the
forecast then we have SIMPLE
notification Services systems and tools
available in Amazon to update us with
notifications through email or through
SMS now anything anything can be send
through email or through SMS if you use
that service it could be alarms or uh it
could be service notifications if you
want stuff like that and then we have
some security tools like KMS key
management system which uses AES 256bit
encryption to encrypt our data at rest
then we have Lambda a service for which
we pay only for the time in seconds
seconds it takes to execute our code and
uh we're not paying for the
infrastructure here it's just the
seconds the program is going to take to
execute the codee if it's a short
program we'll be paying in milliseconds
if it's a bit bigger program we'll be
probably paying in uh 60 seconds or 120
seconds but that's lot cheap lot simple
and lots cost effective as against
paying for service on an odly basis
which a lot of other services are well
that's cheap but using Lambda is a lot
cheaper than that and then we have
services like uh Route 53 at DNS service
in the cloud now I do not have to
maintain an DNS account somewhere else
and my cloud environment with AWS I can
get both in the same place all right let
me talk to you about um how AWS makes
life easier or how companies got
benefited by using AWS as their it
provider for their applications or for
the infrastructure now unil is a company
and um they had a problem right and they
had a problem and they picked AWS as a
solution to their problem right now this
company was sort of spread across 190
countries R and they were relying on a
lot of digital marketing for promoting
their products and their existing
environment their legacy local
environment proved not to support their
changing it demands and they could not
standardize their old environment now
they chose to move part of their
applications to AWS because they were
not getting what they wanted in their
local environment and since then you
know roll outs were easy provisioning
new applications became easy and even
provisioning infrastr structure became
easy and they were able to do all that
in push button scaling and uh needless
to talk about uh backups that are safe
and backups that can be securely
accessed from the cloud as needed now
that company is growing along with AWS
because of their Swift speed in rolling
out deployments and uh being able to
access secure backups from various
places and generate reports and in fact
useful reports out of it that helps
their business now now on the same lines
let me also talk to you about kogs and
how they got benefited by using Amazon
now kogs had a different problem it's
one of its kind now their business model
was very dependent on an INF that will
help to analyze data really fast right
because they were running promotions
based on the analyzed data that they get
so they being able to respond to the
analyzed data as soon as possible was
critical or vital in their environment
and luckily sap running on Hannah
environment is what they needed and uh
you know they picked that service in the
cloud and that's sort of solve the
problem now the company does not have to
deal with maintaining their legacy infra
and maintaining their heavy compute
capacity and maintaining their database
locally all that is now moved to the
cloud or they are using Cloud as their
it service provider and and now they
have a greater and Powerful it
environment that very much complement
their business hi there I'm Samuel a
multiplatform cloud architect and I'm
very excited and honored to walk you
through this learning series about AWS
let me start the session with this
scenario let's imagine how life would
have been without Spotify for those who
are hearing about Spotify for the first
time uh Spotify is an online music
service offering and it offers instant
access to over 16 million licensed songs
Spotify now uses AWS Cloud to store the
data and sh with their customers but
prior to AWS they had some issues
imagine using spotify before AWS let's
talk about that back then users were
often getting errors because Spotify
could not keep up with the increased
demand for storage every new day and
that led to users getting upset and
users canceling the subscription the
problem Spotify was facing at that time
was their users were present globally
and were accessing it from everywhere
and uh they had different latency in
their applications and and Spotify had a
demanding situation where they need to
frequently catalog the songs released
yesterday today and in the future and
this was changing every new day and the
songs coming in rate was about 20,000 a
day and back then they could not keep up
with this requirement and needless to
say they were badly looking for way to
solve this problem and that's when they
got introduced to AWS and it was a
perfect fit and match for their problem
AWS offered a dynamically increasing
storage and that's what they needed AWS
also offered tools and techniques like
storage life cycle management and
trusted advisor to properly utilize the
resource so we always get the best out
of the resource used AWS address their
concerns about easily being able to
scale yes you can scale the AWS
environment very easily how easily one
might ask it's just a few button clicks
and AWS solved spotify's problem let's
talk about how it can help you with your
organization problem let's talk about
what is AWS first and then let's bleed
into how AWS became so successful and
the different types of services that AWS
provides and what's the future of cloud
and AWS in specific let's talk about
that and finally we'll talk about a use
case where you will see how easy it is
to create a web application with AWS all
right let's talk about what is AWS AWS
or Amazon web services is a secure cloud
service platform is also pay as youo
type billing model where there is no
upfront or Capital cost we'll talk about
how soon the service will be available
well the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with AWS you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the flight and almost
all the services are available on demand
and most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak Amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing growing every new week now
that would make you wonder how AWS
became so successful of course it's
their customers let's talk about the
list of well-known companies that has
their it environment in AWS Adobe adob
uses AWS to provide multi- terabyte
operating environments for its customers
by integrating its system with AWS Cloud
adob can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure Airbnb is another company
it's an Community Marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the rbnb community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iPhones and Android
applications Airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in AWS and they're almost
using all the services in AWS and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be Autodesk Autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment Industries
using services like Amazon RDS or
rational database servers and Amazon S3
or Amazon simple storage servers
Autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure AOL or
American online uses AWS and using AWS
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14,000
in-house and collocated servers and move
Mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its Global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
Bit Defender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
softwares include antivirus and anti
spyware products Bit Defender uses ec2
and they're currently running few
hundred instances that handle about 5
terab of data and they also use elastic
load balancer to load balance the
connection coming in to those instances
across availability zones and they
provide seamless Global delivery of
service because of that the BMW group it
uses AWS for its new connected Car
application that collects sensor data
from BMW 7 Series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
canons offers Imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and Global reach by using AWS
to deliver cloud-based services such as
Mobile Print the office Imaging products
division uses AWS such as Amazon S3 and
Amazon Route 53 Amazon cloudfront and
Amazon IM for their testing development
and Production Services Comcast it's the
world's largest cable company and the
leading provider of internet service in
the United States Comcast uses AWS in a
hybrid environment out of all the other
Cloud providers Comcast CH AWS for its
flexibility and scalable hybrid
infrastructure Docker is a company
that's helped helping redefine the way
developers build ship and run
applications this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in AWS the service called
the Amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
European Space Agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and Computing
infrastructure is built on Amazon web
services Esh chose AWS because of its
economical pay as eego system as well as
its quick startup time the Guardian
newspaper uses AWS and it uses a wide
range of AWS services including Amazon
Kinesis Amazon red shift that power an
analytic dashboard which editors used to
see how stories are trending in real
time Financial Times FD is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used Amazon red
shift to perform their analysis A Funny
Thing Happened Amazon red shift performs
so quickly that some analysists thought
it was malfunctioning they were used to
running queries overnight and they found
that the results were indeed correct
just as much faster by using Amazon red
Shi FD is supporting the same business
functions with costs that are 80% lower
than what was before general electric GE
is at the moment as we speak migrating
more than 9,000 workloads including 300
desperate Erp systems to AWS while
reducing its data center footprint from
34 to 4 over the next 3 years similarly
Howard Medical School HTC IMDb
McDonald's NASA Kelloggs and a lot more
are using the services Amazon provides
and are getting benefited from it and
this huge Sues and customer portfolio is
just the tip of the iceberg and if we
think why so many adapt AWS and if we
let AWS answer that question this is
what AWS would say people are adapting
AWS because of the security and durab
ility of the data and endtoend privacy
and encryption of the data and storage
experience we can also rely on aw's way
of doing things by using the AWS tools
and techniques and suggested best
practices built upon the years of
experience it has gained flexibility
there is a greater flexibility in AWS
that allows us to select the OS language
and database easy to use swiftness in
deploying we can host our applications
quickly in AWS be it a new application
or migrating an existing application
into AWS scalability the application can
be easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that to without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that AWS
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database Security customer engagement
desktop and Swit streaming Mission
learning developers tools stuff like
that and if you do not see the service
that you're looking for it's probably is
because AWS is creating it as we speak
now let's look at some of them that are
very commonly used within Computer
Services we have Amazon ec2 Amazon
elastic bean stock Amazon light sale and
Amazon Lambda Amazon ec2 provides
compute capacity in the cloud now this
capacity is secure and it is resizable
based on the user's requirement now look
at this the requirement for the web
traffic keeps changing and behind the
scenes in the cloud ec2 can expand its
environment to three instances and
during no load it can shrink its
environment to just one resource elastic
beanock it helps us to scale and deploy
web applications and it's made with a
number of programming languages elastic
beanock is also an easy to ous service
for deploying and scaling web
applications and services deployed a be
in Java net PHP nodejs python Ruby doer
and a lot other familiar services such
as Apache passenger and IIs we can
simply upload our code and elastic bean
stock automatically handles the
deployment from capacity provisioning to
load balancing to Auto scaling to
application Health monitoring and Amazon
lightell is a virtual private server
which is easy to launch and easy to
manage Amazon lightell is the easiest
way to get started with AWS for
developers who just need a virtual
private server lightell includes
everything you need to launch your
project quickly on a virtual machine
like SSD based storage a virtual machine
tools for data transfer DNS management
and a static IP and that to for a very
low and predictable price AWS Lambda has
taken Cloud Computing Services to a
whole new level it allows us to pay only
for the compute time no need for
provisioning and managing servers and
AWS Lambda is a compute service that
lets us run code without provisioning or
managing servers Lambda executes your
code only when needed and and scales
automatically from few requests per day
to thousands per second you pay only for
the compute time you consume there is no
charge when your code is not running
let's look at some storage services that
Amazon provides like Amazon S3 Amazon
Glacier Amazon EBS and Amazon elastic
file system Amazon S3 is an object
storage that can store and retrive data
from anywhere websites mobile apps iot
sensors and so on can easily use Amazon
S3 to store and retrive data it's an
object storage built to store and drive
any amount of data from anywhere with
its features like flexibility in
managing data and the durability it
provides and the security that it
provides Amazon simple storage service
or S3 is a storage for the internet and
Glacier Glacier is a cloud storage
service that's used for archiving data
and long-term backups and this Glacier
is an secure durable and extremely
lowcost cloud storage service for data
archiving and long-term backups Amazon
EBS Amazon elastic Block store provides
Block store volumes for the instances of
ec2 and this elastic Block store is
highly available and a reliable storage
volume that can be attached to any
running instance that is in the same
availability Zone ABS volumes that are
attached to the E instances are exposed
as storage volumes that persistent
independently from the lifetime of the
instance and Amazon elastic file system
or EFS provides an elastic file storage
which can be used with AWS cloud service
and sources that are on premises an
Amazon elastic file system it's an
simple it's scalable it's an elastic
file storage for use with Amazon cloud
services and for on premises resources
it's easy to use and offers a simple
interface that allows you to create and
configure file systems quickly and
easily Amazon file system is built to
elastically scale on demand without
disturbing the application growing and
shrinking automatically as you add and
remove files so your application have
the storage they need and when they need
it now let's talk about databases the
two major database flavors are Amazon
auds and Amazon red shift Amazon auds it
really easers the process involved in
setting up operating and scaling a
rational database in the cloud Amazon
audius provides cost efficient and
resizable capacity while automating time
consuming administrative tasks such as
Hardware provisioning database setup
patching and backups it sort of frees us
from managing the hardware and sort of
helps us to focus on the application
it's also cost effective and resizable
and it's also optimized for memory
performance and input and output
operations not only that it also
automates most of the services like
taking backups you know monitoring stuff
like that it automates most of those
Services Amazon rad shift Amazon red
shift is a data warehousing service that
enables users to analyze the data using
SQL and other business intelligent tools
Amazon R shift is an fast and fully
managed data warehouse that makes it
simple and and costeffective analyze all
your data using standard SQL and your
existing business intelligent tools it
also allows you to run complex analytic
queries against terabyte or structured
data using sophisticated query
optimizations and most of the results
they generally come back in seconds all
right let's quickly talk about some more
services that AWS offers there are a lot
more services that AWS provides but
we're going to look at some more
services that are widely used AWS
application Discovery Services help
Enterprise customers plan migration
projects by gathering information about
their on premises data centers in a
planning a data center migration can
involve thousands of workloads they are
often deeply interdependent server
utilization data and dependency mapping
are important early first step in
migration process and this AWS
application Discovery service collects
and presents configuration usage and
behavior data from your servers to help
you better understand your workloads
rout 53 it's a network and content
delivery service it's an highly
available and scalable Cloud domain name
system or DNS service and Amazon Route
53 is fully compliant with IPv6 as well
elastic load balancing it's also a
network and content delivery service
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes incoming application traffic
across multiple targets such as Amazon
ec2 instance containers and IP addresses
it can handle the varing load of your
application traffic in a single
availability zones and also across
availability zones a is auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using AWS Autos scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes Auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for DB Services
AWS identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to AWS
services and resources securely using IM
you can create and manage AWS users and
groups and and use permissions to allow
and deny their access to AWS resources
and moreover it's a free service now
let's talk about the future of AWS well
let me tell you something cloud is here
to stay here's what in store for AWS in
the future as years pass by we're going
to have variety of cloud applications
Bor like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence serverless
Computing and so on cloud will also
expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as I was mentioning some time
back lot or greater Focus will be given
to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies moving
into the cloud all right let's now talk
about how easy it is to deploy an web
application in the cloud so the scenario
here is that our users like a product
and we need to have a mechanism to
receive input from them about their
likes and dislikes and uh you know give
them the appropriate product as per
their need all right though the setup
and the environment it sort of looks
complicated we don't have to worry
because AWS has tools and Technologies
which can help us to achieve it now
we're going to use services like Route
53 services like cloudwatch E2 S3 and
lot more and all these put together are
going to give an application that's
fully functionable and an application
that's going to receive the information
uh like using the services like Route 53
Cloud watch ec2 and S3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all I want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated about the happenings
and the new comings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use S3
for storage and S3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloudwatch for
monitoring the environment and
cloudwatch monitors the application and
the environment and it uh provides
trigger for scaling in and scaling out
the infrastructure and we're also going
to use Route 53 for DNS and Route 53
helps us to register the domain name for
our web application and with all the
tools and Technology Oles together all
of them put together we're going to make
an application a perfect application
that CS our need all right so I'm going
to use elastic beant stock for this
project and the name of the application
is going to be as you see GSG signup and
the environment name is GSG signup
environment 1 let me also pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that and the application
that I have is going to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic beant stock this
is going to launch an instance it's
going to launch the monitoring setup or
the monitoring environment it's going to
create a load balancer as well and it's
going to take care of all the security
features needed for this
application
all right look at that I was able to go
to that URL which is what we gave and
it's now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the code or in
specific the page required so let's do
that let me upload the code I already
have the code saved
here that's my code and that's going to
take some time all right it has done its
thing and now if I go to the same URL
look at that I'm being thrown an
advertisement page all right so if I
sign up with my name email and stuff
like that you know it's going to receive
the information and it's going to send
an email to the owner saying that
somebody had subscribed to your service
that's the default feature of this app
look at that email to the owner saying
that somebody had subscribed to your app
and this is their email address stuff
like that not only that it's also going
to create an entry in the database and
Dynamo DB is the service that this
application uses to store data there's
my Dynamo DB and if I go to tables right
and go to items I'm going to see that a
user with name Samuel and email address
so and so has said okay or has shown
interest in the preview of my site or
product so this is where or this is how
I collect those information right and
some more things about the
infrastructure itself is it is running
behind an load balancer look at that it
had created a load balancer it had also
created an autoscaling group now that's
the feature of elastic load balancer
that we have chosen it has created an
Autos Skilling group and now let's put
this URL you see this it's it's not a
fancy URL all right it's an Amazon given
URL a dynamic URL so let's put this URL
behind our DNS let's do that so go to
Services go to rout
53 go to hostage Zone and there we can
find the the DNS name right so that's a
DNS name all
right all right let's create an
entry and map that URL to our load
balancer right and create now
technically if I go to this URL it
should take me to that application all
right look at that I went to my custom
URL and now that's pointed to my
application previously my applic apption
was having a random URL and now it's
having a custom URL so what did we learn
we started the session with what is AWS
we looked at features and tools
Technologies products that AWS provides
and we also looked at how AWS became
very successful again we looked into the
benefits and features of AWS in depth
and we also looked at some of the
services that AWS provides in random and
then we picked particular services and
we talked about them like ec2 elastic
beant stock light sale Lambda storage
stuff like that then we also looked at
the future of AWS what AWS holds in the
store for us we looked at that and then
finally we looked at a lab in which we
created an application using elastic
beant stock and all that we had to do
was a couple of clicks and boom an
application was there available that was
connected to um the database and that
was connected to the simple notification
system that was connected to Cloud watch
that was connected to storage stuff like
that what is azure what's the big cloud
service provider all about so Azure is a
cloud computing platform provided by
Microsoft now it's basically an online
portal through which you can access and
manage resources and services now
resources and services are nothing but
you know you can store your data and you
can transform the data using services
that Microsoft provides again all you
need is the internet and being able to
connect to the Azo portal then you get
access to all of the resources and their
services in in case you want to know
more about how it's different from its
rival which is AWS I suggest you click
on the top right corner and watch the
AWS versus AO video so that you can
clearly tell how both these cloud
service providers are different from
each other now here are some things that
you need to know about as year it was
launched in February 1st 2010 which is
significantly later than when AWS was
launched it's free to start and has a
pay per use model which means like I
said before you need to pay for the
services you use through aor and one of
the most important selling points is
that 80% of Fortune 500 companies use
Azure Services which means that most of
the bigger companies of the world
actually recommend using AZ and then
azir supports a wide variety of
programming languages the cop nodejs
Java and so much more another very
important selling point of aure is the
amount of data centers it has across the
world now it's important for a cloud
service provider to have many data
centers around the world because it
means that they can provide their
services to a wider audience now Azor
has 42 which is more than any cloud
service provider has at the moment it
expects to have 12 more in a period of
time which brings its total number of
regions it covers to 54 now let's talk
about Azure Services now Azure Services
have 18 categories and more than 200
services so we clearly can't go through
all of them it has services that cover
compute a and machine learning
integration management tools identity
devops web and so much more you're going
to have a hard time trying to find a
domain that Azure doesn't cover and if
it doesn't cover it now you can be
certain they're working on it as we
speak so first let's start with the
compute Services first virtual machine
with this service what you're getting to
do is to create a virtual machine of
Linux or Windows operating system it's
easily configurable you can add RAM you
can decrease RAM you can add storage
remove it all of it is possible in a
matter of seconds now let's talk about
the second service cloud service now
with this you can create a application
within the cloud and all of the work
after you deploy it deploying the
application that is is taken care of by
aor which includes you know provisioning
the application load balancing ensuring
that the application is in good health
and all of the other things are handled
by aure next up let's talk about service
fabric now with service fabric the
process of developing a micros service
is great simplified so you might be
wondering what exactly is a micros
service now a microservice is basically
an application that consists of smaller
applications coupled together next up
functions now with functions you can
create applications in any programming
language that you want another very
important part is that you don't have to
worry about any hardware components you
don't have to worry what Ram you require
or how much storage you require all of
that is taken care of by Azure all you
need is to provide the code to azure and
it'll execute it and you don't have to
worry about anything else now let's talk
about some networking Services first up
we have Azor CDN or the content delivery
Network now the AZ CDN service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have expess R now
with this you can actually connect your
on promise Network onto the Microsoft
cloud or any of the services that you
want through a private connection so the
only communication that happens is
between your unpromised network and the
service that you want then you have
virtual Network now with virtual Network
you can have any of the Azure Services
communicate with each other in a secure
manner in a private manner next we have
azard DNS so azur DNS is a hosting
service which allows you to host their
DNS or domain name system domains in
Azure so you can host your application
using Azure DNS now for the storage
Services first up we have dis storage
with dis storage you're given a
costeffective option of choosing HDD or
solid state drives to go along with your
virtual machines based on your
requirements then you have blob storage
now this is actually optimized to ensure
that they can store massive amounts of
unstructured data which can include Text
data or even binary data next you have
file storage which is a managed file
storage and can be accessible via the SB
protocol or the server message block
protocol and finally you have q storage
now with Q storage you can provide
durable message queuing for an extremely
large workload and the most important
part is that this can be accessed from
anywhere in the world now let's talk
about how a y can be used firstly for
application development it could be any
application mostly web applications then
you can test the application see how
well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like I mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual Machines of any size or
Ram that you want you can integrate and
Sync features you can collect and store
metrices for example how the data Works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and you have virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored talk
about Azure in great length and breadth
and if you're looking for a video that
talks and walks you through all the
services and Azure then this could be
one of the best video you could find in
the internet and without any further
delay let's get started everybody likes
stories it so let's get started with a
story in a city not so far away a CEO
had plans to expand his company globally
and called one of his it personel for an
IT opinion and this guy has been in the
company for a long time and is very
seasoned with the company's infra and he
nicely answered the questions with what
he foresaw and he said I have a good
news and a bad news for us to go Global
and he starts with the good news he said
sir we're well on our way to become one
of the world's largest shipping company
and the bad news is however our data
centers have almost run run out of space
and setting up new ones around the world
would be too expensive and very time
consuming now the IT personnel let's
call him Mike now he explains the
situation from how he saw it but the CEO
had done some homework about how he was
going to do it and he answered Mike
saying don't worry about that Mike I've
come up with a solution for a problem
and it's called Microsoft Azure well
Mike is an hardworking and harnessed IT
professional working for that company
but he did not spend time on learning
the latest Technologies and he asked
this question very honestly oh how does
it solve a problem and the CEO begins to
explain Azure to Mike and he starts with
what is cloud computing and then he goes
on and talks about Azure and the service
is offered by Azure and why Azure is
better than the other Cloud providers
and what are the great compan companies
that uses Azure and how they got
benefited out of it and then he winds it
all up with the use cases of azure so he
begins his explanation saying Microsoft
Azure is known as the cloud service
provider and it works on the basis of
cloud computing now Microsoft Azure is
formerly known as Windows Azure and it's
a Microsoft's public cloud computing
platform it also provides a range of
cloud services including some of them
are compute analytics storage and
networking we can always pick and choose
from these services to develop and scale
our applications or even plan on running
existing applications in the public
Cloud Microsoft Azure is both a platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service let's now fit their conversation
out and let's talk about what is cloud
computing azure services offered by
Azure how is azure leading when compared
to other cloud service providers and
what are the companies that are using
Azure let's talk about that in simple
terms cloud computing is being able to
access compute services like servers
storage database networking software
analytics intelligence and a lot more
over the Internet which is the cloud
with the uh flexibility of the resources
that we use like anytime I want a
resource I can use one and it becomes
available immediately and anytime if I
want to retire and resource I can simply
retire at resource and not pay for it
and we also typically pay only for the
services that we use and this helps
greatly with our operating cost to run
our infrastructure more efficiently and
scale our environment up or down
depending on the business needs and
change changes and all the servers and
storages and databases and networking
all that are accessed through the
network of remote systems or remote
computers hosted in the internet
typically in the providers data center
which is azure in this case now we don't
use any physical server or an on
premises server here well we still use
physical servers and VMS you know hosted
on a hardware or a physical server but
they're all in the provider's
environment and none of them sit on
premises or in our data center we only
access them remotely it looks and feels
the same except for the fact that they
are in a remote location we access them
remotely do all the work remotely and
when we're done we can shut it down and
not pay for them so some of the use
cases some of the use cases of cloud
computing are creating applications and
services the other use cases are storing
or using Cloud for storage alone if
there is one thing that ever grows in an
organization is the storage every new
day there is a new storage requirement
and it's very Dynamic it's very hard to
predict and if we go out and buy a big
storage capacity up front and until we
use the storage capacity fully the empty
storages you know we're wasting money on
them so instead I can go for a storage
which scales dynamically that's in the
cloud put storage or put data in the
cloud and pay only for what you're
storing and for the next month if you
have deleted or flushed out some files
or data pay less for it so it's a very
Dynamic storage in the cloud and a lot
of companies are getting benefited from
storing data in the cloud because of its
uh dynamic in nature and the cost that
comes along with it the cheap cost that
comes along with it and also they give a
lot of the providers like Azure they
give a data replication for free they
promise an SLA along with the data we
store in the cloud so there's an SL
attached to it and they also provide
data recoveries as well if in case
something goes wrong with the physical
disk where our data is stored Azure
automatically makes our data available
from the Redundant or other places where
it had stored our data because of the SL
they wanted to keep the other use case
for Azure is hosting websites and
running blogs using the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music Azure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of U CDN content
delivery Network which allows us to
stream a video or audio files with great
speed you know with that with Azure our
audio or video application works
seamlessly because they are provided to
the client with very low latency and
that improves the customer experience
for our application Azure compute
service is a good place for delivering
software on demand there are a lot of
softwares embed softwares that we can
buy using Azure and everything on a pay
asigo service model so anytime we need a
software we can go out and immediately
buy the software for the next one hour
or 2 hour let's say and use them and
then return it back we not bound to any
yearly licensing cost by that aure
Computing Services has analytic
available for us with which we can
analyze ize get a good visualization of
what's going on in a network be it logs
be it the performance be the metrics you
know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over the heaps and heaps of logs
that we have saved Azure analytics
Services helps us to get a good visual
of what's going on in the network where
have we dropped where have we increased
what's causing what's the major driver
what is the top 10 errors that we get in
the server in the application stuff like
that those can be easily gathered from
the Azure analytic Services now cloud is
really a very cool term for the internet
a good analogy would be looking back
anytime we look at a diagram when we do
not know how things are transferred we
simply draw a cloud right for example a
mail gets sent from a person in one
country to a person in the other country
there a lot of things happening in
between from the time you hit the send
button and the time the other person
hits the read button right and we the
simple and the easiest way of putting it
in a picture is simply draw a cloud and
on the one end one person will be
sending the email and on the other end
the other person will be reading the
email so cloud is a really cool term for
the internet now that's some Basics
about cloud computing now now that we've
understood about cloud computing in
general let's talk about Microsoft Azure
as a cloud service now Microsoft Azure
is a set of cloud services to build
manage and deploy applications on a
network with the help of Microsoft
azures Frameworks now Microsoft Azure is
a Computing service created by Microsoft
basically for building testing deploying
and managing applications and services
through a Global Network of Microsoft
managed data centers now Microsoft Azure
provides SAS which is software as a
service and PAs which is platform as a
service and IAS infrastructure as a
service and they support many different
programming languages tools and
framework and those tools and framework
include both Microsoft specific and
thirdparty software now let me pick and
talk about a specific service for
example management Azure automation
provides a way for us to automate the
manual long running and frequently
repeated tasks that are commonly
performed tasks both in cloud and
Enterprise environment it saves a lot of
time and increases the reliability and
it kind of gives a good administrative
control and even schedules the task
automatically to be performed on a
regular basis to give you a quick
history of Microsoft Azure it was
launched on 1st February
2010 and it was awarded or it was called
an industry leader for infrastructure
and platform as a service by Gartner now
Gartner is the world's leading research
and advisory company this Microsoft
Azure supports a number of programming
languages like C Java and python all
these School Services we get to use and
pay only for how much we use for example
if we use for an R we only get to pay
for an R even the costliest system
available if you use them for an hour we
only pay for that particular hour and
then we're done no more billing on the
resource that we have used Microsoft
Azure has spread itself more than 50
regions around the world so it's quite
easy for us to pick a region and you
know start provisioning and running our
applications probably from day one
because the infrastructure and the tools
and Technologies needed to run our
application are already available all
that we have to do is come at the code
in that particular region or build an
application and launch it in that
particular region and they become live
starting day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide load latency services to our
customers all right instead of In
traditional data center let's say you
know customers will have to or their
request will have to travel all the way
around the globe to reach a data center
which lives in the other side of the
planet and this adds more latency to it
and it is really not feasible to build a
data center uh near each customer
location because of the cost involved
but with Azure it's possible Azure
already has data centers around the
world and all that we have to do is just
pick a data center build an environment
there they're available starting day one
number one and also the cost is
considerably saved because we are using
a public Cloud instead of an physical
infrastructure to serve those customers
from a very local location and these
services that as your is offering is
ever increasing as of now as we speak we
have like 200 plus services offered and
uh they span through different domain or
different platform or different
Technologies available within the Azure
console portal now we're going to talk
about that later in this section so hold
your breath till we talk about it but
for now just know that we have like 200
plus services offered by Azure let's now
talk about different services and aure
starting with artificial intelligence
plus machine learning
where we have a lot of tools and
Technologies so the wide variety of
services available on Azure includes
artificial intelligence plus machine
learning plus analytic services to get
an or to give us a good visual of how
the data or how the application is
performing or the type of the category
of data stored and to read from the logs
and variety of compute Services
different VMS with different size in
different operating systems different
containers available different type of
databases available a lot of developer
tools that are available for us and
identity service to manage our users in
the Azure cloud and those users can be
integrated or Federated with let's say
Google Facebook you know LinkedIn so
they are some external Federation
Services they can be used to integrate
with our ident system iots iot Services
iot tools and Technologies available and
management tools to manage the users you
know creating identities one and then
managing them on top of it is a totally
different thing and we have tools
Technologies to manage the uh users cool
services for data migration data
migration is now made simple tools and
Technologies available for mobile
application uh development and I can
plan my own network in the cloud with
the networking Services I can Implement
my own security both Azure provider and
third party Security Services on Azure
Cloud that's now possible and lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in Azure
Cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in a specific specific
let's take compute for example you know
whenever we're building a new
application or deploying existing ones
the Azure compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that Azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or Linux wi
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options Azure provides for us
to migrate our VMS to Azure and lot more
and these compute Services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or in on premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides provides
some of the services the computer domain
provides are virtual machines and this
Azure virtual machines gives us the
ability to develop and manage a virtual
computer environment or a virtualized
environment inside azures Cloud
environment that to in a virtual private
Network now we will talk about virtual
private Network at a later point but as
of now just know that there are a lot of
service is available in Azure compute
service that we can get benefited from
we can always choose from a very wide
range of uh computer options for example
you know we have an option to choose the
operating system we have the option to
choose whether the system should be in
on premises or in the cloud or do we
want to maintain the environment both in
on premises and in the cloud we have the
option of choosing the operating system
whether we want to use our own operating
system syst with some software attached
to it or do we want to go and buy the
operating system from the cloud from
Azure Marketplace and these are just a
few of the options available for us when
we want to buy the compute environment
and these computer environments are
easily scalable meaning we can easily
scale our VM instances from one instance
to thousands of virtual machines in a
matter of minutes or simply put in a
couple of button clicks and all these
services are available on a pay for what
we use model meaning there is no upfront
cost we use the service and then pay for
the services that we have used there's
no literal long-term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a pay per minute billing basis
all right and at no point because of the
pay per minute billing model at no point
we will be overpaying for any of the
services that's that's attractive isn't
it now let's talk about batch service
now bat service is always independent
regardless of whether you choose windows
or Linux it's going to run fairly well
and with bat servers we can take
advantage of the environment's unique
features and not only that in short the
bat service helps us to manage the whole
batch environment and also it helps to
schedule the jobs now this Azure batch
service is actually runs on a large
scale parallel and high performance
Computing because of that batch jobs are
highly efficient in Azure and when we
run batch services this Azure batch
creates a pool of computer nodes and uh
installs the needed applications that we
want to run and then it schedules jobs
to those individual nodes in those pools
as a customer there is there's no need
for us to install a cluster or there is
no need for us to install a software
that actually schedules the jobs or even
to manage or even to scale those
infrastructure or the software because
everything is managed by Azure and this
bat service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for I mean the
only charges that we'll be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and uh the storage that we will be
using of course and uh the networking
services that we will be using for this
batch service let's summarize this batch
service we have a choice of operating
system that we can pick and use and it
scales by itself now the alternative for
the batch would be cues but in cues
we'll have to pre-provision and pay for
the infrastructure even if we're not
using it but with a batch we only pay
for what we use and this batch service
helps us to manage
the application manage the scheduling as
a whole as if they are just one thing as
next thing in compute domain let's talk
about this fabric service now this
fabric service is actually a distributed
system platform that helps us to package
deploy and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this Azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developer and administrators so they can
avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what's service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and uh life cycle
management to applications that are
composed of microservices no
infrastructure management at all and
with service fabric we can easily scale
the application to tens or hundreds or
even to thousands of machines here
machines represent containers as next
thing in compute domain let's talk about
virtual machine scale set now this
virtual machine scale set it lets us to
create a group of identical load
balanced VMS I just want to mention it
again it helps us to manage a group
identical and load balanced VMS the
number of instances or the number of VM
instances in an in a scale set can
increase or decrease in response to uh
the demand or in response to a schedule
that we Define you know the resources
needed on a Monday morning is not the
same as that would be required on a
Saturday or a Sunday morning all right
and even within the day the resources
that would be needed in the beginning of
the business hour is not the resources
that would be needed at noon or you know
after 8 or 9 in the evening so the
demands could actually vary in the
environment and the scale set helps us
to take care of the varing demand or
take care of the uh different
infrastructure requirement at a
different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the scal set also allows us to provide
High availability to our applications
and it helps us to uh centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
VMS as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machine
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine scale set just like I said this
virtual machine scale set helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes uh the requests to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set it helps
us to create a large number of identical
virtual machines number one and with
scale set we can increase or decrease
the virtual machines with virtual
machine scale set we can centrally
manage and configure and update a big
group of VMS and it's a great use case
when it comes to Big Data or container
workloads as next thing in compute
domain uh let's talk about cloud
services now this Azure cloud service is
actually a platform as a service and
it's very friendly in fact it is
designed for applications that support
scalability or an application that
requires scalability or reliab
and and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive to operate so Azure
cloud service provides all these so
where would this cloud service run well
it runs on a VM but it's a platform as a
service VMS are infrastructure as a
service and when we run applications on
VM through cloud service it becomes
platformed as a service so here is how
you got to be thinking with
infrastructure as a service like VMS we
first create and configure the
environment and then we run application
on top of it let's look at the
responsibility the responsibility for us
in VM is that we manage everything end
to end like uh you know deploying new
patches picking the versions of the
operating system and making sure they
are uh intact and all that stuff it's
all managed by us but on the contrary
with platform as a service it's I mean
it's as if the environment is already
ready all that you have to do is deploy
your application in it and manage the
platform I mean manage the platform not
as an administrator because all the
administration is taken care by Azure
like know deploying new versions of the
operating system it's all handled by the
Azure so we deploy the application and
we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
Azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
uh where we can uh write the uh
application code and we don't have to
worry about Hardware simply hand over
the code and cloud service takes care of
of it so no worry on the hardware at all
so responsibilities like patching what
do we do if something uh crashes how do
I update the infrastructure how do I
manage uh the maintenance or the
downtime in the underlying
infrastructure all that is handled by
Azure it also provides an good testing
environment for us you know we can
simply run the code test it before it's
actually released to the production I
want to expand a bit on the testing
applications so this Azure cloud service
it actually gives us an staging
environment for testing a new release
without it affecting the existing
release which actually reduces the
customer downtime so we can run the
application tested and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become from the new staging environment
where we can uh add more to it and then
swap it back at a later point so it it
kind of gives us an swapable environment
for testing our applications and not
only that it gives us Health monitoring
alerts it helps us to monitor the health
and availability of our application
there is a dashboard we can benefit from
uh when we use Azure cloud services and
that shows the key statistics all in one
place and we can also set up realtime
alerts one when a service availability
or a certain metrics that we are
concerned about degrades as next thing
in computer domain let's talk about
functions now functions are serverless
Computing now many time if you heard
about Azure being serverless a lot of
time they are referencing or the person
who's talking to you is referencing to
serverless uh Computing or Azure
functions which is a serverless
Computing service hosted on Microsoft
Azure the main motive of a function is
to accelerate and simplify application
development functions helps us to run
code on demand without we need to
pre-provision or manage any Azure
infrastructure so Azure functions are
script or a piece of code that gets run
in response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running uh that code and
the best of all the best is when we use
functions we only pay for the time that
our code runs so what does functions
provide or what does Azure functions
provide Azure functions allow users to
build applications using serverless uh
simple functions with a programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is c f nodejs Java and PHP so here we
really don't have to worry about
provisioning or uh maintaining servers
if a code requires more resource yes
Azure functions handles or it provides
the additional resources needed by the
code and the best part is we only pay
for the amount of time the functions are
running not the resources but the amount
of time the function is running as next
thing and moving to the new domain let's
talk about the container domain in Azure
now the container domain or the
container service it allows us to
quickly deploy a production ready
kubernetes or a Docker swamp cluster now
what's a container a container is a
standard unit of software that packages
of code and all its dependencies so the
applications run quickly and reliably
from one Computing environment to
another it could be testing uh to
staging to developing development
environment to staging to production or
from one production to another
production or on premises to cloud or
one Cloud to another Cloud vice versa
now imagine we had an option not to
worry about the VM and just focus on the
application well that's exactly what
containers helps us achieve so these
container instances enable us to focus
on applications and not worrying about
managing VMS or not worrying about the
Laing the new tools required to manage
the VMS or even the deployment and our
applications that we create they run in
a container and running in a container
is what helps us to achieve all these
not being able to manage or not needing
to manage the virtual machines so these
containers uh they can be deployed into
the cloud using a single command if
you're using command line interface and
a couple of button clicks if we are
using the Azure portal and these
containers are kept lightweight but they
are equally secure as virtual machines
let's talk about container service as
next thing uh the container service or U
sometimes called as Azure kubernetes
service it helps us to manage the
containers container is one thing and a
service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or ACS it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this Azure container
service or ACS it it actually provides a
way uh to simplify the creation
configuration and management of a
cluster of virtual machines that are
preconfigured to run containerized
applications on top of them and
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provisioned we can actually manage them
by using simple SSH tunnel into them and
this ACS when it runs application it
runs applications from Docker images
what does that mean a Docker image
makes sure that the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and ACS also helps us to or
orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even tens of thousands of containers so
in a nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using AKs or ACS is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is Made Simple using this container
services and even training of model
using a large data set in a complex and
resource intensive uh environment this
AKs helps us to simplify that uh
environment all right as next thing in
container domain let's talk about
container registry we spoke about
registry a little bit when we spoke
about Docker images so container
registry is a single place where we can
store our images which are Docker images
when we use when we use containers it's
it's Docker images that we use for our
image purposes so these container images
are a central registry that can be used
to ease container development by easing
the storage
and management of container images so
there we can store all kind of images
like U Docker swamp or the images used
in Docker swarm or in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in Azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for geo replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions now this Geo replication it
actually enables us to manage Global
deployments assuming we are having an
environment that requires a global
deployment so it helps us to manage
Global deployments as one entity because
we are Geor replicating we would be
updating we would be editing one image
and that image gets replicated
throughout the global uh replication
centers we would have set up and so just
one editing would have actually edited
the global images and those global
images would have provisioned the global
application so one edit replication and
then provisioning of the applications
globalwide and this replication also
helps us to helps us Network latency
because you know anytime an application
needs to deploy it does not have to rely
on a single source which which can be
reached only through high latency
Network because we have Global
replications around the world anytime
the application wants to check back it
would check back uh the application
which is in a very nearby location for
the application itself Global
replication means that we are managing
it as a single entity that's being
replicated across the multiple regions
in the globe as next thing in a learning
let's talk about um Azure databases now
this Azure databases are rational in
fact they have uh many flavors in them
uh we're going to look at uh different
flavors no SQL no SQL cache type of
database that Azure offers so we're
going to learn one at a time or we're
going to learn one by one so this Azure
SQL database is a rational database in
fact it's a rational database as a
service it's managed by Azure we don't
get to do a lot of management in it so
it's a rational database as a service uh
based on Microsoft uh SQL Server
database engine and this database is a
high performance database it is very
reliable and uh it's very secure as well
and this High reliability high
performance and for this high security
we really don't have to do anything it
comes along with it and uh it's managed
by Azure and there are two things that I
definitely need to mention about Azure
SQL database that is it's an intelligent
service number one it's fully managed by
Azure and it also has this one good
thing which is it has built-in
intelligence that learns app patterns
and adapts to maximize performance and
reliability and data protection of the
application that's something that's not
found in uh many of the other Cloud
providers that I'm aware of so I thought
I'll mention it so it uses built-in
intelligence to learn about um the
user's database patterns and helps
improve performance and protection and
migration or importing data is very easy
when it comes to Azure SQL database so
it can be readily or immediately used
for analytic reporting and uh
intelligent applications in Azure as
next thing let's talk about Azure cosmod
DB now Azure cosmod DB is a database
service that is for no SQL type and uh
it's it's created to provide low latency
and uh an application that scales
dynamically or that scales rapidly now
this Azure cosmod DB is an a globally
distributed service
and it's a multimodel database this can
be provisioned in a click off a button
that's all we got to do if we need to
provision and Azure Cosmo DB in the
Azure it helps with scaling the database
know we can elastically and
independently scale throughput and
storage across this database and in any
of the Azure geographic regions it
provides a good throughput it provides
good latency it provides good
availability and um it provides or Azure
promises a a comprehensive SLA that no
other database can offer that's the best
part about cosmod DB so this cosmod DB
was built with global distribution in
mind and it's built uh with the
horizontal scale in mind and all this we
can use by only paying for what we have
used and remember the difference between
Azure cosmod DB and the SQL database is
that Azure cosmod DB CS no SQL whereas
SQL doesn't all right few other things
about Azure cosmod DB is it allows users
to use key value graph a column family
and document data it also gives users a
number of AP options like SQL JavaScript
mongod DB and and few others that you
might want to check in the document at
at the time of reading and the best part
here is that all that we mentioned we
get to use only by paying for the amount
of storage and throughput that are
required and the storage and the
throughput can be elastically scaled
based on the requirement of the r all
right let's talk about um redis cache
discussion about Azure database won't be
complete without we talking about redis
cache now reddis cache is a secure data
cache it's also called it's also
sometimes called as messaging broker
that provides high throughput and low
latency access to data for the
applications now redis cache is based on
an a popular open-source caching product
which is that is sometimes called as L
is cache now what's the use case it's
typically used to Cache to improve the
performance and scalability of a system
that rely heavily on backend data stores
now performance when we use redis cache
is improved by temporarily copying the
frequently accessed data to a fast
storage located very close to the
application now with redis cache this
fast storage is located in memory with
redis cache instead of being loaded from
the actual dis in the database itself
now this redis Cache can also be used as
an in-memory data structure store not
only that it can be used as an
distributed non-relational database and
a message broker so there are variety of
uh use cases for this redis cache and by
using RIS cach the application
performance is improved by taking
advantage of the low latency and the
high throughput performance that this
redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this redis cach is actually backed by
Red server and it supports u a string
hashes linked list and various other
data structures now let's talk about
security and identity Services now ident
identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principle identities you might ask
now what's an principal identity now
Identity or principal identity are
Services applications users groups and a
lot more the speciality about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in Cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid Cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multiactor authentication it can provide
access policies based on condition a
permit or deny based on condition it can
also monitor suspicious activity and not
only that it can also report it it can
also help generate alerts for potential
security issues and in a way to mitigate
it can send us an alert so we can get
involved and prevent an security
accident from happening so let's talk
more about identity management so some
of the services under security an
identity management or Azure security
center now this Azure security Center
provides Security Management and threat
protection across the workloads in both
cloud and in the hybrid environment it
helps control user access and
application control to stop any
malicious activity if present it helps
us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
deduct attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen and it also works
seamlessly with hybrid environments so
you don't have to have one policy for on
premises and one policy for the cloud
it's now a Unified Service both for on
premises and the cloud the next service
in security and identity would be keyal
now a keyal is a service or a feature
that helped safegard the cryptographic
keys and any other Secrets used by the
cloud applications and the services in
other words this Azure keyal is a tool
for securely storing and accessing the
secrets of the environment I mean the
secret Keys now a secret is anything
that you really want to have a very
tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if I tell you what keyal
actually solves that would actually
explain what keyal is now keyal is used
in Secrets management it's helped in
securely storing The Tokens The
passwords the certificates it helps in
Key Management you know it really helps
in creating and controlling the
encryption keys that we would use to
encrypt data it helps in certificate
management talking about certification
management it helps us to easily
provision manage and employ public and
private SSL TLS certificates in Azure
and a lot more so in a nutshell this key
wall it provides users the ability to
provision new walls and keys in just a
matter of minutes all that in a single
command or all that in a couple of
button clicks it also helps users to
centrally manage their Keys Secrets and
policies next in the list let's talk
about Azure active directory now Azure
active directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities what what does that mean now
this Azure active directory is a
cloudbased active directory and identity
management service now Azure active
directory combines and it's actually a
combination of the core directory
Services Plus application access
management plus identity protection
and one good thing about this Azure in
fact there are a lot of good things but
especially when you're running hybrid
environments you might wonder well how
this Azure active directory is going to
behave now this Azure active directory
is built to work on on premises and
Cloud environment as well not only that
it also works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well so in a nutshell
this Azure active directory it acts as
an central point of identity and access
management for our Cloud environment it
also provides good Security Solutions
that protect against unauthorized access
of our app and the data now that we have
discussed about security and identity
let's talk about the management tools
that Azure has to offer Azure provides
builtin management and account
governance tools that helps
administrators and developers that helps
them to keep their sources secure and
very compliant and again it helps both
in on premises and in the cloud
environment and these management tools
help us to monitor the infrastructure
monitor the applications it also helps
in provisioning and configuring
resources it also helps in updating apps
it helps in analyzing threats taking
backup of the resources build uh
disaster recoveries it also helps in
applying policies and conditions s to
automate our environment we use Azure
management tools and it's also used in
cost control methods so this Azure
management plays a wide role across the
Azure services and in the management
tools first comes the Azure advisor now
this Azure advisor it acts as a guide to
educate us about Azure best practices it
throws recommendations that we can
select on the basis of the category of
servers and it also provides the impact
it can have or the impact that would
happen in our environment if we follow
the recommendations given and
recommendations are first one is the
recommendations are kind of templatized
and it throws um the templatized
recommendations not only that it also
provides customized recommendations on
the basis of the configuration on the
basis of our usage patterns and these
recommendations are not hard it's not
like something that it recommends and
then just leaves us hanging there these
recommendations provided are very easy
to follow very easy to implement and see
results you can think of azure advisor
as an a Very personalized Cloud
consultant that helps you to follow best
practices to optimize our deployments it
kind of analyzes our resources our
configurations our usage and then it
recom mends a solution for us that
really helps in improving the cost
Effectiveness improving the performance
improving High availability and
improving Security in our Azure
environment so with this Azure advisor
we can get a proactive actionable and
personalized best practice
recommendations now you don't have to be
an expert just follow the Azure advisor
and your environment is going to be good
it also helps and improve the
performance security High availability
of our environment and also it helps in
bringing down the overall Azure spend
and the best part is it's a free service
that analyzes our Azure usage and
provides recommendations how we can
optimize our Azure resource to reduce
cost and reduce cost at the same time
boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment next in the list would be
Network watch ER now this network
Watcher helps users identify and gain
insights in the overall Network
performance and the health of the
overall environment now these Azure
Watchers provides enough tools to
monitor to diagnose to view the metrics
and to enable or disable logs which
means you know generate and collect the
logs for resources in the Azure virtual
Network so with network Watcher can
monitor and diagnose issues in
networking without even logging into the
virtual machines with just a logs which
are real time we can actually come to a
conclusion what could be wrong in a
certain resource in a VM or in a
database you know but just looking at
the logs and not only that it's used for
analytic or to gain some intelligence of
what's happening in our Network we can
gain a lot of insight to the current
Network traffic pattern using the
security group flow logs that this
network Watcher offers it also helps in
investigating VPN connectivity issues
using detailed logs now you might or
might not know that you know VPN
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties and other person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs in our end stuff like that
but with the network Watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix and the next in the list
would be Microsoft Azure portal now this
Microsoft Azure portal it provides a
single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize our environment or the
appearance of the environment or the
visual of the environment based on our
workstyle and using Azure portal users
can control who gets to manage or access
the resources all from the Azure portal
and this Azure portal gives a very good
visibility on the spins that happen on
each resource right and if we can
customize it we can also identify spend
based on on team spends based on days
spends based on Department stuff like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual of where the money is spending or
where is the bill consumed within the
Azure environment next in the list would
be Azure resource manager now Azure
resource manager enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
Monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typically made of various components
which includes virtual machine storage
virtual Network web app database servers
some other third party services that we
might use in our environment and they
are by nature separate services but with
Azure resource manager we don't see them
as different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports an
application now we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them spread Azure resource
manager identifies the relation between
them and helps us to visually see them
all as one or single entity not only
that Azure resource manager helps or it
ensures that the resources that we
provision or deploy at a constant rate
along with the other application it also
helps users to visually see their
resources and how they are connected and
that helps in managing the resources a
lot better resource Group also is used
to control who can access the resources
within the user's organization kind of
gives you the fine grained control over
who gets to access and who does not get
access and the last one in the
management tools would be automation aut
and this automation gives us the ability
to automate configure and install
upgrades across hybrid environments it
provides a cloud-based Automation and
configuration service not only that this
can be applied for non aure environments
as well which is on premises so some of
the automation we could do is process
automation update management automation
configuration features automation stuff
like that and this Azure automation
provides complete heat control during
the deployment operation and also during
the decommissioning of the workloads and
resources with automation we can
actually automate uh time consuming or
mundane or any task that's error prone
because of uh human errors those things
can be automated so irrespective of how
many times you run it it's going to run
the same way and that really helps in
reducing the overall time and also the
overhead cost because a lot of the
things are automated which means it's
human error free which means the
application is not going to break and
keep running for a longer time with
automation we can actually build a good
inventory of operating system resources
and configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes is
it's easy to track easy to identify easy
to identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the Azure management tools or
Management Services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in Azure there are
variety of services especially
networking services that Azure offers
and I'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery Network
now the content delivery Network in
short CDN it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as load times it also helps in Saving
bandwidth and increases in respons iess
to the application let's expand on this
the content delivery network is actually
a distributed network of servers that
can efficiently deliver web content to
users now cdns we're going to use the
word CDN here CDN store cached content
on global Edge servers also called as uh
pops point of presence locations that
are very close to the end users so the
latency is minimized it's like taking a
copy of the data or taking a multiple
copy of the data and storing it in
different parts of the world and whoever
is requesting it the data gets delivered
to them from a server which is very
locally to them so this CDN offers
developers a global solution for rapidly
delivering high bandwidth content to
users by caching the content in a
strategically placed location which is
very near to them so these content
delivery networks it really helps in
handling that's one advantage you get
for Content delivery Network that's we
can handle spikes and heavy loads very
efficiently and we can also run analytic
against the logs that gets generated in
content delivery Network which helps in
gaining good Insight on the workflow and
what would be the future business need
for that application and this just like
a lot of other services this is on a pay
as you go type so you use the resource
first and then you only pay for what you
have used the next one in networking
would be express route now express route
is actually a circuit or a link that
provides an a direct private connection
to Azure and because it's direct it
gives low latency link to Azure it gives
good speed and reliability for the Azure
data transfer it could be on premises to
Azure so it gives very good speed it
gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit now this express route is
an service that actually provides an
private connection between Microsoft
Data Center and infrastructure in our
premises or in a different cocation
facility that we might have now these
Express routes do not go over the public
internet and because they don't go over
the public internet they offer a high
security reliability and speed and low
latency compared to the connections
which are in the internet because it's
fast because it's reliable because it it
has low latency it can be used as an
extension of our existing data center
you know users are not going to feel the
difference whether they are accessing
services from an on premises or in the
cloud environment because latency is
minimized as much as possible you users
are really not going to see the
difference and because it's a private
line and not an public internet line it
can be used to build hybrid applications
without compromising privacy or the
performance now these virtual private
Cloud these Express routes can be used
for taking backups if Zoom a backup
going through the internet that would be
a nightmare if you use express route for
backups that's going to be fast and
imagine recovering a data through the
internet from the cloud through the
internet to the on premises in a time of
disaster that would be the worst
nightmare so these Express routes can be
used not only to backup but also to
recover the data because it provides
good speed low latency recovering the
data is going to be lot sooner the next
product or service we're going to
discuss in networking is azure DNS now
Azure DNS allows us to host domain name
in Azure and and these domain names come
with an exceptional performance and
availability now Azure DNS is used to
set up and manage DNS zones and records
for our domain name in the cloud now
this Azure DNS is a service for DNS just
like the name says and it provides name
resolution by using azures
infrastructure and uh by using this
domain we can actually manage the DNS
ourselves through the Azure portal with
the same credential imagine having a DNS
provider which does not even belong in
our it imagine that environment you know
we would have a separate portal to
manage the DNS environment now those are
gone and now we can actually manage the
DNS in the very same Azure portal where
we use the rest of the other services
and this Azure DNS very much integrates
with other DNS service providers it uses
a Global Network of name servers to
provide fast response to DNS queries and
these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other uh
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because most
of the servers are maintained by
Microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps resyncing let's say a server fails
it kind of helps resyncing with the rest
of the servers so all the Microsoft's
environment all the Microsoft's Global
Network of name servers kind of ensures
that our domain names are resolved
properly not only properly but also are
available most of the time right next in
the list in networking Services is
virtual Network I'm sure this is going
to be very interesting and I'm sure
you're going to like it so this
networking or virtual networking in
Azure it actually allows us to set up
our own private fit cloud in the public
Cloud it gives us an isolated and highly
secure environment for our application
let's expand on this and this Azure
virtual Network helps us to provision
Azure virtual machines and uh it helps
us to securely communicate with other on
premises and internet networks it also
helps in controlling the traffic that
flows through or Flows In and Out of
This virtual net Network to other
virtual networks and to the internet now
this Azure virtual Network sometimes
called as wiet is actually a
representation of our own network in the
cloud it's actually a logical isolation
of the Azure Cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a vnet that is separate
from another customer's vets that way we
have that logical separation there so
this virtual Network can also be used to
provision of vpns in the cloud so we can
connect the cloud and the on premises uh
infrastructure and a lot more especially
in a environment where we have hybrid
environment surely we will be using
virtual Network because that's going to
require VPN for secure data transfer in
and out of the cloud and in and out of
the on premises environment all right so
it kind of gives us an boundary for all
the resources so all the traffic between
the Azure resources they kind of
logically stay in between or logically
stay within the Azure virtual Network
and here we can design the network it's
given over to us you know you can pick
the IP you can pick the routing you can
pick the subnet and a lot of freedom is
given or I would say a lot of control on
how the networ is designed it's not like
something that's already cooked and we
only get to use it no we can actually
build the network from the scratch we
can pick the IP address that we like we
can pick you know which subnet needs to
communicate with the other subnet stuff
like that and like I said if you are
using hybrid environment you definitely
would be requiring a virtual Network
because it helps connect the on premises
and the cloud in a secure fashion using
VPN the last product we're going to
discuss in networking is a load balancer
this load balancer actually provides
application a good a availability and a
good Network performance so how does it
work it actually works by load balancing
the traffic to and from the virtual
machine and the cloud resources not only
that it also load balances between cloud
and cross premises virtual networks with
azured load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means Our obligation will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences up time all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the TCP and UDP
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even Millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the backend pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains High availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high a aable scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user's application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
That's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
Services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in Azure now Azure storage in general is
a a Microsoft manage service providing
cloud storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
Azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these Azure storages are a group of
storage Services they C different needs
and the storage products include Azure
blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes um Azure data Lake
it includes Azure files as you see it it
includes Azure cues it includes Azure
tables and lot more but let's start our
discussion with Azure store simple Azure
store simple is an hybrid cloud storage
solution that actually lowers the cost
off storage to nearly 60% of how much
you would be actually spending without
using it so Azure simple storage or
store simple is an integrated storage
solution that manages the storage task
between on premises and the cloud
storage what I really like about Azure
is that it's built around a hybrid
environment in mind there are a lot of
other Cloud providers that are there
where running and hybrid environment is
a big challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or a on premises and Cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with the Azure especially when it
comes to storage a lot of the things
that we're going to see it clearly is
designed with hybrid environment in mind
all right so let's come back and talk
about store simple so store simple is an
very efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable sand storage area
networking solution in the cloud I
thought I'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series device which are used in Azure
Data Center and this uh store simple or
simple storage it comes along with
storage steering to manage the stored
data across the various storage media so
the current the very current data is
actually stored in on premises on solid
state drives and data that is used less
frequently is stored in uh hdds or hard
disk drives and the data that requires
archived or that needs to be archived
very old data let's say less frequently
use data candidate for archive they are
actually pushed to the cloud so you see
how this storage steering automatically
happens in store simple and one another
cool feature of store simple is that it
enables us to create an OnDemand and
scheduled backups of data and and then
store the data locally or in the cloud
and these backups are actually taken in
the form of incremental snapshot which
means that they can be created and
restored quickly it's not a complete
backup it's an incremental backup and
these Cloud snapshots they can be
critically important when there is a
disaster and when there is a disaster
recovery scenario because these
snapshots can be called in and they can
be put on storage systems and then they
become the actual data so recovering is
faster if you have proper scheduled
backups or if you have frequent backups
and this storage simple it really helps
in easing our backup mechanism which
means it kind of eases our Disaster
Recovery steps or procedures as well so
this store simple it can be used to
automate data management data migration
data movement data teering across the
Enterprise both in cloud and on premises
it actually improves the compliance and
accelerates the disaster recovery for
our environment and if there is one
thing that's increasing every new day in
our environment that would be storage
and this store simple addresses that
need and we really don't have to
pre-plan or or think in deep or having a
proper storage because now we have a
simple storage available in the cloud
and moreover it's on a pay as you go
type so not much pre-planning on storage
is needed yes there would be a need but
not as much as I would without the cloud
or without the simple storage and the
next servers under storage that we would
like to discuss is the data Lake store
this data Lake store or storage it's a
coste effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this data Lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
Lake store and this data Lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and of any injection speed and it kind
of collects them in one single space or
in one one single place for operational
efficiency I mean operational efficiency
and for analytic purpose Hado in Azure
is very dependent on this data Lake
storage and this uh data Lake store is
designed with performance for analytics
in mind so anytime you think of or
anytime you're using analytic in the
cloud or anytime you're using Hado in
the cloud in Azure we are definitely
using or we will be to the most part or
the noral procedure or the Right Storage
to pick would be data L store in Azure
it's designed with security in mind so
anytime we use Azure storage we can be
rest assured that we are using storage
from within a data center which has or
which was built with security in mind so
this data store also uses Azure blob
storage behind the scenes for global
scale durability and for performance
let's talk about blob storage now blob
storage provides large amount of storage
and scalability now this blob storage is
the object storage solution for Azure
Cloud let's expand a bit on blob storage
Azure blob storage is Microsoft offering
for object storage now this blob storage
is optimized for storing massive amount
of unstructured data which could be text
or binary data it's designed and it's
optimized for Rapid reads if I explain
to you on what scenarios we would be
using blob storage that might help you
get a good understanding of what blob
storage is so it's help or it's designed
as of now it's being used in many it
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
access a lot of Fetchers can fetch data
from Azure blob storage and it currently
helping users stream video and audio
it's currently being used for writing
log file FES it's currently being used
to store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of Disaster
Recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud it
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned uh it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates and data a new version
gets created which means at any point I
can roll back as in when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the users's storage need it
also supports tearing of the data So
based on need when I actually explore I
would find a lot of options I can pick
from that uh you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like I said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be Q storage now Q storage
provides durable qes for large volume
cloud services it's a very simple and a
cost effective durable messaging queue
for large workloads let's expand this Q
storage for a moment now this Q storage
is a service for storing large amount of
messages that can be accessed from
anywhere in the world through HTTP and
https calls a single queue or a single
CU message can be up to like 24 KB in
size and a single Q can contain millions
of such 24 KB in size messages and how
much can it hold it can hold up to the
total capacity of the storage account
itself so that's kind of easy to
translate How much would it hold and
this Azure Q storage it provides an
messaging solution between applications
and components in the cloud what does it
help it helps in designing an
application for scale it helps in
decoupling the application so you know
it's not very dependent or sometimes
it's not at all dependent on the other
application because now we have a Que in
between which kind of translates or
which kind of connects or which kind of
decouples both the environment now we
have a queue in between both the
environment can scale up or scale down
independently the next in the storage
service would be file storage let's talk
about file storage now these Azure files
provide secure simple and managed Cloud
file shares now with file share in the
cloud it actually extends the user
servers on premises performance and
capacity and lot of familiar tools for
the cloud file share management can be
used along along with the file storage
that we're talking about so let's expand
a bit on file storage now this Azure
files or Azure file storage offers a
fully managed file shares in the cloud
that can be accessed via the uh SMB
protocol server message block protocol
now this Azure file shares can be
mounted concurrently by cloud or in on
premises deployments a lot of operating
systems are compatible with it windows
are compatible Linux is compatible MACC
OS is compatible in in addition to all
these being able to run on on premises
and on the cloud or being able to access
from on premises and on the cloud it can
also offer cache for caching uh the data
and keeping it locally so it's
immediately available when needed so
that's some additional feature I would
say that's some Advanced feature that it
offers compared to the other file shares
available in the market let's talk about
table storage let's talk about table
storage now table storage is a nosql key
value pair storage for quick deployments
with the large semi-structured data sets
the difference between one important
thing to note with table storage is that
it has a flexible data schema and also
it's highly available let's expand a bit
on table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less a no SQL type table
storage is the one will end up picking
it provides an key pair attribute
storage with a schema less design this
table storage is very fast and very cost
effective for many of the applications
and for the same amount of uh data it's
lot cheaper when you compare it with the
traditional SQL data or data storage so
some of the things that we can store in
the table storage are of course they're
going to be flexible data sheets uh such
as user data for web application address
books device information and other types
of metadata for our service requirements
and it can have any number of tables up
to the capacity limit of the storage
account now this is not possible with
SQL this is only possible with no SQL
especially with table storage in Azure
explanation of storage really concluded
the length and breadth of the
explanation this CEO was giving his uh
it personal but this ID personal is not
done with it yet he still has a question
even after this lengthy discussion and
his question was well there are a lot of
other Cloud providers available what
made you specifically choose Azure I
mean from the kind of question that he
asked we can say that he is very curious
and uh he definitely had asked an very
thoughtful question so his CEO went on
and started to explain about the uh
other capabilities of Azure or how it
kind of outruns the rest of the cloud
providers so he started or he again
started his discussion but from a
different angle now so he started to
explain what are the capabilities or how
Azure is better than uh the competitor
so he started with explaining the
platform as a service capabilities and
I'm going to tell you what the CEO told
his ID person so this platform as a
service or in platform as a service the
INF structure management is completely
taken care by uh Microsoft allowing
users to focus completely on the
innovation no more infrastructure
management responsibilities go and focus
on Innovation that's that's a fancy way
of saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on Innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and uh Azure especially is U net
friendly Azure supports the net
programming language and um it has or it
is built or designed or it is optimized
to work with old and new applications
deployed using net programming framework
so if your application isnet most of the
time you would end up picking Azure I
mean if you try to compare most of the
time you would end up picking Azure as
your cloud service provider and the
security offerings that Azure offers is
it's designed based on the security
development life cycle which is an
industry-leading assurance process when
we buy services from Azure it aures that
the environment is designed based on
security development life cycle and like
I mentioned many times in the past and I
would like to mention it again Azure has
well thought about the hybrid
environments which a lot of other Cloud
providers have failed so it's very easy
to set up an hybrid environment to
migrate the data or not to migrate the
data and still run a hybrid environment
they work seamlessly with the Azure
because Azure provides seamless
connection across on premises data
centers and the public Cloud it also has
a very gentle learning curve if you look
at the uh documentation it's picture
rich and the documentations are neat and
clear would really it would encourage
you to learn more it would encourage you
to think and imagine and try easily get
get a grasp of how Services work so it
has a very gentle learning curve Azure
allows the utilization of technologies
that several business have used for
years so there is a big history behind
it it has a very gentle learning curve
the the certifications the
documentations the stage-by-stage
certification levels it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing in other cloud service providers
now this would really impress the CTO or
or people working in finance and
budgeting if an organization is already
using Microsoft software they can
definitely go and Avail or be bold and
ask for a discount that can reduce the
overall Azure spending in other words
overall pricing of the Azure so that's
what helped or they are the information
that helped the CEO pick Azure as his
cloud service provider and then the CEO
goes on and talks about the different
companies that are currently using azure
and they are definitely using Azure for
a reason like Pixar Boeing Samsung
EasyJet Xerox BMW 3M they are major
multinational multi-billion companies
they rely run operate their it in Azure
and this CEO has a thought that his it
person is still not very convinced
unless and until he shows him a visual
of how easy things are in Azure so he
goes on and explains about a practical
application of azure which is what
exactly I'm going to show you as well
all right a quick project on building an
Azure app using or building a net
application in Azure web app and making
it connect to anql database will
solidify all the knowledge that we have
gained so far so this is what we're
going to do I have an Azure account open
as you see logged in and everything is
fresh here let me go to Resource Group
there's nothing in there it's it's kind
of fresh all right I'm logged in and
this is what we're going to do so we're
going to create an application like this
which is nothing but an to-do
application a to-do list application we
is going to run from the web app get
information from us and save it in the
database that's connected to it so you
can already see it's a two-tier
application web and DB all right so let
me go back to my Azure account the first
first thing is to create an Resource
Group let's give it an a meaningful name
let's call it Azure simply Lear all
right and it's going to be a free trial
and the location pick one that's nearest
to you or you know wherever you want to
launch your application now for this use
case I'm going to pick Central us and
create it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and an a
separate SQL database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on ADD it's not
the web app plus SQL that we want we
want web app alone for this uh example
so let's create an web app uh give it a
quick name let's call it uh Azure simply
learn the subscription is free trial and
I'm going to use my existing Resource
Group a resource Group that we created
some time back it's going to run out of
Windows and we're going to publish the
code all set we can create it all right
while this is running uh let me create
my uh
database right SQL database create a
database give it a name let's call it
Azure simply learn
DB put it in our existing Resource Group
that that we created it's going to be a
blank database all right and it's going
to require some uh settings like the
name of the server and the admin login
the password that goes along and in
which location this is going to be
created the server name is going to be
Azure simply learn DB that's the server
name and the admin login can be what can
be the admin login name let's see so
let's call it simply La that's my admin
login name and let me pick a
password click on create so what have we
done so far we have created an web app
and we have created an a database in the
resource Group that we have created so
if I go to Resource Group it's going to
take some time before things show up so
if I go to my Resource Group I only have
one Resource Group as of now as you
simply learn and there I have a bunch of
resources being created you know it's
still being created right in the
meantime I have my application right
here that's running out of uh or that's
in Visual Studio as of now right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready in
the Azure console uh we're going to go
back to visual studio a feed these
inputs in the visual studio so the code
knows what the database is the the
credentials to log into the database
stuff like that so we're going to feed
those information in Visual Studio by
that we're actually feeding it into the
application and then we're going to run
it from there deploying this application
takes uh quite a while we really got to
be patient all right now we have all the
resources that we need for the
application to run here is my uh
database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is um create an firewall exception
rule so one more thing needed is to
create an firewall exception uh rule
right so the application is going to run
from my local desktop and it's going to
connect to the uh uh database right so
let's add an exception rule by simply
adding the client IP it's going to pick
my IP the IP of laptop I'm using as of
now and it's going to create an
exception to access the database so
that's done now we can go back to our
Visual Studio I already have a couple of
um apps running or couple of uh
configurations pushed from Visual Studio
I'm going to clean that up if you're
doing it for the first time you you may
not uh need to do
this all right so let's start from the
scratch this is very similar to how you
would be doing in your environment all
right so we're going to uh select an
existing Azure app service now before
that I have logged in as you can see I
have logged in with my credential so
it's going to pull few things
automatically from my Azure account so
in this case I'm going to use an
existing Azure app so select existing
and then click on
publish all right if you recall these
are the very same resources that we
created a while
back right we have clicked on Save and
it's it's running kind of validating the
code and it's going to come up with an
URL now initially the URL is uh not
going to work because we haven't mapped
the application to the database that
would be the next
thing
all right so the app has been published
and it's running from my a web app as of
now it's going to throw an error like
you see it's throwing an error that's
because we haven't mapped the app and
the DB together so let's do
that all right let's do that so let's go
to server Explorer uh this is where uh
we're going to see our uh databases that
we have created now let's quickly verify
that go back to uh the resource Group
right appropriate Resource Group which
is right here and uh here I have my U
database Azure simply learn
database
all right it has some issues connecting
uh to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix
it
all right so we'll have to map
the database into this application all
right so let's go to the solution
Explorer click on
publish and a page like this get shown
and from here we can go to
configure here is our web app all right
with all its uh credentials let's
validate the connection number
one all right and then click on
next this is my DB connection string
right which the app is going to use to
connect to my DB now if you recall rdb
was uh Azure simply learn DB and that's
not being shown here so let's fix
that right so let's fix
that click on configure and here uh
let's put our DB servers uh URL now
before that let's change this to SQL
Server all right and then in here uh put
the DB's URL so go back to Azure here is
my DB or server's name put that
here right the username to connect to
the server that's right here put that in
and the
password to connect to the server let's
put that
in all right right it's trying to
connect to our Azure portal or the Azure
infrastructure and here is my database
if you recall it's Azure sldb that's the
name of the database Let's test the
connection connection is good click on
okay so now it's showing up correctly
Azure simply learn DB that's the name of
uh the database that we created now it's
configured
all right let's modify the data
connections
right let's map it to the appropriate
database again all right so our name of
the database is azure simply Lear
DB and then uh it's going to be SQL
Server that's the data source the
uh username is simply learn and the
password is what we have given in the
beginning all right let's validate the
connection it's good click
okay now we're all set and ready to
publish our application again now the
application knows how to connect uh to
the database we have educated it with
the um the correct connection strings
the DNS name the username and the
password for the application to connect
to the
database so visual studi is building
this project and once it is up and
running we'll be prompted with an URL uh
to connect and anytime we put or we give
inputs to the URL that's going to
receive the input and save it in the
database
all right so here is my uh to-do list
app and uh I can start uh creating to-do
list for myself all right so I have the
items already listed I can create an
entry and these entries get stored in
the U in the database I can create
another entry and I'll take the dog for
a while walk that's going to get stored
I can create another entry uh book
tickets for uh scientific uh
exhibition and that's going to receive
and put that in the database and that
concludes our session so through this
session we saw how I can use Azure
services to create web app and connect
that to the DB instance and how those
two Services which are decoupled by
default def which are separate by
default how I can you know use the
connection strings to make connection
between the app server and the database
and be able to create an working app hi
guys I'm rul from Simply learn and today
I'd like to welcome you all to the
greatest debate of the century today I'm
joined by two giants of the cloud
computing industry they'll be going
head-to-head with each other to decide
who amongst them is better it's going to
be one hell of fight now let's meet our
candidates on my left we have AWS who
voiced by AA hi guys and on my right we
have Microsoft AO who is voiced by
Angeli hey there so today we'll be
deciding who's better on the basis of
their origin and the features they
provide their performance on the present
day and comparing them on the basis of
pricing market share and options free
tier and instance configuration now
let's listen to their opening statements
let's start with AWS launched in 2006
AWS is one of the most commonly used
cloud computing platforms across the
world companies like Adobe Netflix
Airbnb HTC Pinterest and Spotify have
put their faith in AWS for their proper
functioning it also dominates the cloud
computing domain with almost 40% of the
entire market share so far nobody's even
gotten close to beating that number AWS
also provides a wide range of services
that covers a great number of domains
domains like compute networking storage
migration and so much more now let's see
what Azor has to say about that Azor was
launched in 2010 and is trusted by
almost 80% of all Fortune 500 companies
the best of the best companies in the
world choose to work only with Azure
Azure also provides its services to more
regions than any other cloud service
provider in the world Azure covers 42
regions already and 12 more are being
planned to be made AA also provides more
than 100 Services spanning a variety of
domains now that the opening statements
are done let's have a look at the
current market status of each of our
competitors this is the performance
round here we have the stats for the
market share of AWS Azo and other cloud
service providers this is for the early
2018 period Amazon web services takes up
a whopping 40% of the market share
closely followed by aor at 30% and other
cloud services adding 30% this 40%
indicates most organizations clear
interest in using aw us we are number
one because of our years of experience
and Trust we've created among our users
sure you're the market leader but we are
not very far behind let me remind you
more than 80% of the Fortune 500
companies trust Azure with their cloud
computing needs so it's only a matter of
time before Azure takes the lead the
rest of the 30% that is in AWS or Azure
accounts to the other cloud service
providers like Google Cloud platform
Rackspace IBM software and so on
now for our next round the comparison
round first we'll be comparing pricing
we'll be looking at the cost of a very
basic instance which is a virtual
machine of two virtual CPUs and 8 GBS of
RAM for AWS this will cost you
approximately
0.098 per hour and for the same instance
in aor it will cost you approximately
0.096 per hour next up let's compare
market share and options as I mentioned
before AWS is the Undisputed market
leader when it comes to the cloud
computing domain taking up 40% of the
market share by 2020 AWS is also
expected to produce twice its current
Revenue which comes close to $44 billion
not to mention AWS is constantly
expanding its already strong roster of
more than 100 services to fulfill the
shifting business requirements of
organizations all that is great really
good for you but the research company
Gardner has released a magic quadrant
that you have to see you see the
competition is now neck to neck between
Azure and AWS it's only a matter of time
before Azure can increase from its 30%
market share and surpass AWS this
becomes more likely considering how all
companies are migrating from AWS to
Azure to help satisfy their business
needs Azure is not far behind AWS when
this comes to Services as well azure's
service offerings are constantly updated
and improved on to help users satisfy
their cloud computing requirements now
let's compare AWS and azor's free
offerings AWS provides a significant
number of his services for free helping
users get hands-on experience with the
platform products and services the free
tier Services fall under two categories
services that will remain free forever
and the others that are valid only for
one year the always free category offers
more than 20 services for example Amazon
SNS sqs cloud watch Etc and the valid
for a year category offers approximately
20 services for example Amazon S3 ec2
elastic cache Etc both types of services
have limits on the usage for example
storage number of requests compute time
Etc but users are only charged for using
services that fall under the valid for a
year category after a year of their
usage a sh provides a free tier as well
it also provides services that belong to
the categories of free for a year and
always free there are about 25 plus
always free services provided by aure
these include app service functions
container service active directory and
lots more and as of the valid for a year
there are eight services offered there's
Linux or Windows Virtual machines blob
storage SQL database and few more Azure
also provides the users with credits of
$200 to access all their services for 30
days now this is a unique feature that
Azure provides where its users can use
their credits to utilize any service of
a choice for the entire month now let's
compare instance configuration the
largest instance that AWS offers is that
of a warping 256 GBS of RAM and 16
virtual CPUs the largest that aure
offers isn't very far behind either 224
GBS of RAM and 16 virtual CPUs and now
for the final round now each of our
contestants will be shown facts and they
have to give explanations for these
facts we call it the rapid fire round
first we have features in which AWS is
good and azur is better AWS does not cut
down on the features it offers its users
however it requires slightly more
Management on the users part Azure goes
slightly deeper with the services that
fall under certain categories like
platform as a service and infrastructure
as a service next we have hybrid Cloud
where AWS is good and Azure is better
okay although AWS did not emphasize on
hybrid Cloud earlier they are focusing
more on technology now Azure has always
emphasized on hybrid cloud and has
features supporting it since the days of
its inception for developers AWS is
better and Azure is good of course it's
better because AWS supports integration
with third party applications well Azure
provides access to data centers that
provide a scalable architecture for
pricing both AWS and aure are at the
same level it's good for AWS because it
provides a competitive and constantly
decreasing pricing model and in the case
of azure it provides offers that are
constantly experimented upon to provide
its users with the best experience and
that's it our contestants have finished
giving their statements now let's see
who won surprisingly nobody each cloud
computing platform has its own pros and
cons choosing the right one is based
entirely on your organization's
requirements hi guys guys today we' got
something very special in store for you
we're going to talk about the best cloud
computing platform available Amazon web
services uh Rahul I think you said
something wrong here the best cloud
computing platform is obviously Google
Cloud platform no it isn't AWS is more
than 100 services that span a variety of
domains all right but Google Cloud
platform has cheaper instances what do
you have to say about that well I guess
there's only one place we can actually
discuss this a boxing ring so guys I'm
AA and I I will be Google Cloud platform
and I'm Rahul I'll be AWS so welcome to
fight night this is AWS versus gcp the
winner will be chosen on the basis of
their origin and the features they
provide their performance in the present
day and comparing them on the basis of
pricing market share and options the
things they give you for free and
instance configuration now first let's
talk about AWS AWS was launched in 2004
and is a cloud service platform that
helps businesses grow and scale by
providing them services in a number of
different domains these domains include
compute database storage migration
networking and so on a very important
aspect about AWS is its years of
experience now AWS has been in the
market a lot longer than any other cloud
service platform which means they know
how businesses work and how they can
contribute to the business growing also
AWS has over $5.1 billion of Revenue in
the last quarter this is a clear
indication of how much faith and trust
people have in AWS they occupy more than
40% of the market which is a significant
chunk of the cloud computing Market they
have at least 100 services that are
available at the moment which means just
about every issue that you have can be
solved with an AWS service now that was
great but now can we talk about gcp I
hope you know that gcp was launched very
recently in 2011 and it is already
helping businesses significantly with a
suite of intelligent secure and flexible
Cloud Computing Services it lets you
build deploy and scale applications
websites services on the same
infrastructure as Google the intuitive
user user experience that gcp provides
with dashboards Wizards is way better in
all the aspects gcp has just stepped in
the market and it is already offering a
modest number of services and the number
is rapidly increasing and the cost for a
CPU instance or Regional storage that
gcp provides is a whole lot cheaper and
you also get a multi-regional cloud
storage now what do you have to say on
that I'm so glad you asked let's look at
present day in fact let's look at the
cloud market share of the fourth quarter
of 2017 this will tell you once and for
all that ad is the leader when it comes
to cloud computing Amazon web services
contributes 47% of the market share
others like Rackspace or Verizon cloud
contribute 36% Microsoft aure
contributes 10% the Google Cloud
platform contributes 4% and IBM software
contributes 3% 47% of the market share
is contributed by AWS do you need me to
convince you anymore wait wait wait all
that is fine but we only started a few
years back and have already grown so
much in such a less span of time time
haven't you heard the latest news our
revenue is already a billion dollar per
quarter wait for a few more years and
the world shall see and AWS makes $5.3
billion per quarter it's going to take a
good long time before you can even get
close to us yes yes we'll see now let's
compare a few things for starters let's
compare prices for AWS a computer
instance of 2 CPUs and 8 GB ram costs
approximately $68 us now a computer
instance is a virtual machine in which
you can specify what operating system
Ram or storage you want to have for
cloud storage it costs 2.3 cents per GB
per month with AWS you really want to do
that because gcp wins this hands down
let's take the same compute instance of
two CPUs with 8 GB Ram it will cost
approximately $50 per month with gcp and
as for my calculations that's a 25%
annual cost reduction when compared to
AWS talking about cloud storage cost it
is only 2 cents per GB per month with
gcp what else do you want me to say
let's talk about market share and
options now AWS is the current market
leader when it comes to cloud computing
now as you remember we contribute at
least 47% of the entire market share AWS
also has at least 100 services available
at the moment which is a clear
indication of how well AWS understands
businesses and helps them grow yeah
that's true but you should also know
that gcp is steadily growing we have
over 60 services that are up and running
as you can see here and a lot more to
come it's only a matter of time but and
we will have as many services as you do
many companies have already started
adopting gcp as a cloud service provider
now let's talk about things you get for
free with AWS you get access to almost
all the services for an entire year with
usage limits now these limits include an
hourly or by the minute basis for
example with Amazon ec2 you get 750
hours per month you also have limits on
the number of requests to services for
example with AWS Lambda you have 1
million requests per month now after
these limits are crossed you get sh
standard rates with gcp you get access
to all Cloud platform products like
Firebase the Google Maps API and so on
you also get $300 in credit to spend
over a 12 Monon period on all the cloud
platform products and interestingly
after the free trial ends you won't be
charged unless you manually upgrade to a
paid account now there is also the
always free version for which you will
need an upgraded billing account here
you get to use a small instance for free
and find 5 GB of cloud storage any usage
above this always free usage limits will
be automatically built at standard rates
now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with AWS the largest
instance that's offered is of 128 CPUs
and 4 TVs of ram now other than the on
man method like I mentioned before you
can also use spot instances now these
are for situations where your
application is more fall tolerant and
can handle an interruption now you pay
for the spot price which is effective at
a particular hour now these spot prices
do fluctuate but are adjusted over a
period of time the largest instance
offered with Google cloud is 160 CPUs
and 3.75 TBS Ram like spot instances of
AWS Google Cloud offers shortlived
compute instances suitable for bad jobs
and fall tolerant workloads they are
called as preemptable instances so these
instances are available at 80% off on on
demand price hence theyve reduce your
compute engine cost significantly and
unlike AWS these at a fixed price Google
Cloud platform is a lot more flexible
when it comes to instance configuration
you simply choose your CPU and RAM
combination of course you can even
create your own instance types this way
before we wrap it up let's compare on
some other things as well Telemetry it's
a process of automatically collecting
periodic measurements from remote
devices for example GPS gcp is obviously
better because they have Superior
Telemetry tools which help in analyzing
services and providing more opportun
these for improvement when it comes to
application support AWS is obviously
better since they have years of
experience under their bet AWS provides
the best support that can be given to
the customers containers are better with
GCB a container is a virtual process
running in user space as kubernetes was
originally developed by Google gcp has
full native support for the tool other
cloud services are just fine-tuning a
way to provide cuberes as a service also
the containers help with abstracting
applications from their environment they
originally run the applications can be
deployed easily regardless of their
environment when it comes to geographies
AWS is better since they have a head
start of a few years AWS in this span of
time has been able to cover a larger
market share and geographical locations
now it's time for the big decision so
who's it going to be yeah who is it
going to be gcp or AWS I think I'm going
to go for choosing the right cloud
computing platform is the decision
that's made on the basis of the user or
the organization's requirement AWS aure
and gcp are three of the world's largest
cloud service providers but how are they
different from each other let's find out
hey guys I'm Rahul and I'll be
representing Amazon web services I'm
chinay and I'll be representing
Microsoft Azure and I'm shuti and I'll
be representing Google Cloud platform so
welcome to this video on AWS versus
Azure versus gcp talking about market
share Amazon web services leads with
around 32% of the worldwide public cloud
share aour owns up to 16% of the
worldwide Market share and gcp owns
around 9% of the world's market share
let's talk about each of these service
providers in detail AWS provides
services that enable users to create and
deploy applications over the cloud these
services are accessible via the Internet
AWS being the oldest of the lot was
launched in the year 2006 aure launched
in 2010 is a Computing platform that
offers a wide range of services to build
manage and deploy applications on the
network using tools and Frameworks
launched in the year 2008 gcp offers
application development and integration
services for its end users in addition
to Cloud management it also offers
services for Big Data machine learning
and iot now let's talk about
availability zones these are isolated
locations within data center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about AWS
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions this includes
regions in the United States South
America Europe and Asia Pacific they are
also predicted to have 12 more additions
in the future azour available in 140
countries has over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers gcp is available in 200
plus countries across the world as of
today gcp is present in 61 zones and 20
regions with Osaka and Zurich being the
newly added regions now let's talk about
pricing these Services follow the pay as
you go approach you pay only For The
Individual Services you need for AOW
long as you use them without requiring
long-term contracts or complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and GPU now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for AWS we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in Hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run on your
applications azor's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that azour offers azour gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual Network gcps VM service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these Services awcc 2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's free
tier that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
Linux and Windows Virtual machines Azure
virtual machine service is a part of the
free tier that offers the service for
about 750 hours per month for a year the
user gets access to Windows and Linux
virtual machines gcps VM service is a
part of a free tier that includes micro
instance per month for up to 12 months
now let's talk about platform as a
service or past services for AWS elastic
bean stock is an easy to use service for
deploying and scaling web applications
and services developed with Java net
nodejs Python and much more it is used
for maintaining capacity provisioning
load balancing Auto scaling and
application Health monitoring the pass
backbone utilizes virtualization
techniques where the virtual machine is
independent of the actual Hardware that
hosts it hence the user can write
application code without worrying about
the underlying Hardware Google app
engine is a cloud computing platform as
a service which is used by Developers
for hosting and building apps in Google
data centers the app engine requires the
apps to be written in Java or Python and
store data in Google big table and use
the Google query language for this next
let's talk about virtual private server
Services AWS provides light sale it
provides everything you need to build an
application or website along with the
cost effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
VM image is a more comprehensive image
for Microsoft Azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless Computing Services AWS has
Lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required Azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the program
programming language of their choice gcp
Cloud functions make it easy for
developers to run and scale code in the
cloud and build event-driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fall tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers First off we
have object storage AWS provides S3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the Internet blob storage is an Azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in Microsoft's Cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tiers depending on how often
data is being accessed Google Cloud
Storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on Google
Cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
Google Drive Google Cloud Storage is
more suitable for Enterprises it also
stores objects that are organized into
bu markets Amazon provides EBS or
elastic Block store it provides high
performance block storage and is used
along with E2 instances for workloads
that are transaction or throughput
intensive Azure manage dis is a virtual
hard disk you can think of it like a
physical dis in an on- premises server
but virtualized these managed discs
allow the users to create up to 10,000
VM discs in a single subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data after power to
the device is shut off Google persistent
disk is durable and high performance
block storage for gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either Google
compute engine or cuetes engine next up
we have Disaster Recovery Services AWS
provides a cloud-based recovery service
that ensures that your it infrastructure
and data are recovered while minimizing
the amount of downtime that could be
experienced site recovery helps ensure
business continuity by keeping business
apps and workloads running during
outages it allows recovery by
orchestrating and automating the
replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database Services
first off for AWS we have RDS or
relational database service it is web
service that's cost- effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
Microsoft Azure SQL database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of SQL Server databases
without changing the users's
applications cloudsql is a fully managed
databased service which is easy to set
up maintain and administer relational
post SQL MySQL and SQL Server databases
in the cloud hosted on gcp cloudsql
provides a database infrastructure for
app applications running anywhere next
we have no SQL database Services AWS
provides Dynamo DB which is a managed
durable database that provides security
backup into the store and inmemory
caching for applications it is well
known for its low latency and scalable
performance Azure Cosmos DB is
Microsoft's globally distributed
multimodel database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports no
SQL created for low latency and scalable
applications gcp cloud data store is a
nosql database service offered by Google
on the gcp it handles replication and
scales automatically to your
applications load with cloud data stores
interface data can easily be accessed by
any deployment Target now that we know
what cloud computing is let's look at
the types of cloud computing service
models for a better understanding let's
consider a scenario consider baking
lasagna you have four options you can
either bake it at home or you can go to
a restaurant to eat lasagna or walk into
an event and bake or get it delivered to
your doorstep but how is this related to
cloud computing well let's take a look
we have four boxes we have the
traditional method we have the
infrastructure as a service we have
platform as a service and we have
software as a service in the traditional
method everything is made at home and
all the components are managed by us
that is Kitchen electricity microwave
lasagna sheets then toppings meat and
cooking the lasagna but when it comes to
infrastructure service the main kitchen
appliances are managed by the vendor and
the other things are managed by us so
basically the infrastructure is managed
by the vendor when we look at platform
as a service the infrastructure and the
main ingredient for the software is
managed by the vendor and the other
things are managed by us but when we
look at software as a service everything
from the infrastructure till the end
product is managed by the vendor now
let's get into brief of all this when we
look at the traditional method
everything is done from the scratch from
choosing the right ingredients to the
mode of preparation and you have the
full control of the toppings this is
similar to traditional method where all
the hardware and software components are
built by our choice of requirements when
we look at infrastructure as a service
we can say kitchen electricity and
microwave is the infrastructure and this
is where the code runs the next step is
to alter the software as per our
requirements when you look at platform
as a service uh it's similar to going to
event and baking so you have the main
ingredient that is the lasagna sheet and
then you have all the appliances that is
Kitchen electricity and microwave and
the rest is managed by us you can either
put toppings or you don't want to put
meat or you want it to be wed it's all
up to us so the components are altered
as per our requirements finally in
software as a service the entire thing
is modeled by the vendor so this is
where you just given your requirements
and you get the software delivered to
you it's basically where the deployment
and framework of the project is already
set now that we have a brief of all
these Services let's dive deep into each
one of them first we have infrastructure
as a service infrastructure cloud
provider gives a variety of
infrastructures such as storage Services
Network hardware and so on it also
maintains and supports these
infrastructures customers can access
these resources over the Internet next
let's look at the benefits of
infrastructure as a service so the first
feature is that these resources can can
easily be scaled up and down next the
cost depends on the consumption so
basically it's a pay as you go pricing
and you pay for what you use you pay for
the services you use a single piece of
server can give out a lot of information
to many users and finally the client has
complete control over the architecture
now let's look at the pros of
infrastructure as a service model
firstly it is highly flexible this is
because only the infrastructure is
provided and the rest depends on the
customer requirements next like I said
before it is cost effective and you pay
for what you use it is easy to use as
all the updates are deployed and all the
hardware is deployed automatically
management tasks are virtualized so that
the other employees have time for other
tasks now let's look at few of its call
it is a multi-tenant architecture due to
this there is an issue with data
security when a new infrastructure is
introduced team training is required to
learn all about this new infrastructure
and and it consumes a lot of time if in
case the server crashes at the vendor
side the customers cannot access the
data for a while and they would have to
wait for a quite a lot of time until the
vendor fixes this issue now that we know
what infrastructure as a service is
let's look at platform as a service
platform as a service cloud computing
platform is a developer programming
platform which is used for the
programmers to develop test and run and
manage the applications a developer
writes the applications and deploys it
directly into this layer here all the
infrastructure to run the applications
will be over the Internet let's look at
the benefits now firstly the resources
can be scaled Up and Down based on the
requirements of the user multiple users
can access the same application it
allows for testing and hosting apps in
the same environment the web services
and databases and servers are integrated
into one and finally the teams can
collaborate very easily next let's look
at the pros of paas firstly the
development process is quick and easy as
it is a developer programming platform
it is coste efficient you only pay for
the services you use when you use
platform as a service the coding is done
by the developer before so less coding
is required and then the migration to
hybrid cloud is very easy next let's
look at few of the cons of platform as a
service similar to IAS data security is
an issue because it has a multi-tenant
architecture there's a compatibility
issue with the existing infrastructure
pass is dependent on the vendor speed
reliability and support now that we know
about platform as a service let's go
ahead and dive deep into software as a
service in software as a service
everything is done by the vendors the
endusers are only responsible to give
their requirements and everything is
done by the providers now let's go ahead
and look at its benefits the
installations and updations are done by
the providers resources are scaled Up
and Down based on the requirements of
the users the only requirement is that
there has to be a strong network
connectivity and finally the provider is
responsible for everything now let's go
ahead and look at the pros of SAS
upgrades are automatic firstly then next
it is again a pay as you go model it is
easier to customize in SAS rather than
the other service models it is
accessible from any location the only
constraint is that you need to have a
strong internet connectivity let's see
the cons of SAS the provider has entire
control the end users only have the
control of giving the requirements there
are only few solutions for software
crashes the devices should always be
connected for better performance now
that we've seen all the three models
let's see few of the companies providing
these service models the famous IAS
providers are Amazon web services
Rackspace digital ocean lenoe and
Microsoft AO these are only a few there
are many more apart from these Amazon
offers many features such as Auto
scaling Cloud monitoring and load
balancing features when it comes to
Rackspace the cloud computing platform
vendor focuses primarily on Enterprise
level hosting Services when you look at
Famous past providers you have hero
Apache Stratos open shift Microsoft
Azure and many other providers going
ahead in SAS providers the most
important one is Google Apps then
there's Salesforce there's Cisco WebEx
there's Dropbox and many more finally
let's look at the end end users of the
cloud computing service models we can
picture this as a pyramid so in IAS the
end users are system admins who are
responsible for maintaining everything
except the infrastructure then in past
the end users are the developers who
code on the platform provided by the
vendors in SAS the end users are the
customers who give only the requirements
and the software is built based on those
requirements by the vendors we have
reached the end of this session on cloud
computing fundamentals and cloud
computing service models should you need
any assistance PP and other resources
used in this session please let us know
in the comment section below and our
team of experts will be happy to help
you as soon as possible until next time
thank you and keep learning stay tuned
for more from Simply learn staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered EXP explore our impressive
catalog of certification programs in
Cutting Edge domains including data
science cloud computing cyber security
AI machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here